figma is a vector graphics editor and
prototyping tool that is great for
designing websites in this course joy
will show you how to use it
joy is a prolific and excellent tutorial
creator
hey guys joy here this is a figma
tutorial for complete beginners
and today you and me together we're
going to make a complete responsive web
design
both for the desktop version and another
one for the mobile version
so this is the home page of our desktop
version so do you see this
nav items over here
home teachers contact us sign in
according to this
nav items we have four pages okay let me
walk you through all the pages and
sections okay so this is the home page
i'm in the landing page over here and
then if i scroll down then we're gonna
find this section over here and then
this section over here our offered
courses this is an educational website
okay and then if i scroll down then
you're gonna find this over here and
then lastly we have this footer over
here all right let me zoom out a little
bit
and this is the teachers section over
here you can see that so this is a
teacher section over here we're going to
make some cards over here along with
some buttons and we're going to also
work with svgs this is the footer over
here for this page and then we have this
contact us
page over here you can see that so we're
going to also work with icons you see
these icons over here we're going to
work with them and also make some forms
over here as well
you can check out the signup page over
here as well this is the last page you
can download this entire figma file
through the link in the description down
below so once you download the figure
file you're gonna find all of these
pages over here so this carries the
desktop design i mean this one over here
and this one carries the mobile design
look at that we have
the mobile design over here okay so this
is our home page let me walk you through
this okay
so this is the home page over here and
these are the style guides i mean the
typographic guides that we're gonna
follow okay what will be the
font size of the logo font size of the
large text font size of the button text
etc every design carries the style ahead
okay let me show you
the mobile carries the style guide the
laptop
the tablet design carries the style
guide as well the laptop design also
carries the style guide over here and
the desktop version this one look at
this at the very top we're gonna find
this style guide over here
so once you download the figma file
you're gonna find all of these pages
over here you see this
the desktop carries the design for the
desktop version and the mobile page
carries the design for the mobile
version okay so i'm gonna click over
here also you're gonna find design for
the laptop and the tablet version as
well
over here
so this is the web design for the mobile
version okay let me actually zoom in a
little bit like that look at that this
is our homepage over here and then this
is the next section third section fourth
section and this is our footer over here
okay let me zoom in a little bit there
we go
and then we have our
social media icons over here as well
and then look at this teacher section
over here
and this is the rest of the design
so today you and me together we're gonna
design the desktop version okay this one
and the mobile version do you see this
laptop and tablet
this is your homework after this
tutorial
you're gonna practice over here okay
you're gonna make this web design for
the tablet version and also you're gonna
make the web design for the laptop
version as well okay
so these two are your homeworks
this entire video is divided according
to these chapters over here this one
over here
you're gonna find the timestamps on the
description down below
so first of all we're gonna look at all
the tools figma carries
so once we have covered all the tools
figma carries then we're going to start
making our responsive web design for the
desktop version first
and then we're going to start making the
web design for the mobile version
by the way this entire video is made for
beginners who doesn't know anything
about sigma so we're gonna start from
scratch i will not use any plugins
libraries or design systems just plainly
from scratch we're gonna use all the
tools that sigma provided and we're
gonna make the design using those tools
only if this video gets at least 2 000
likes then i'm gonna make another video
advance level figma tutorial
where i'll be covering how to make a web
design using the design system plugins
libraries prototypes and also how to
save time as well
so hit the like button and also hit the
subscribe button so that your brother
can afford a massive suzuki 800. this
one
[Music]
also note that these are our breakpoints
okay for the desktop version it is 1440
pixels okay and for the laptop version
it is 1024 pixels and for the tablet
version this is 768 pixels and for the
mobile version i have picked the 414
pixels which is the width of the iphone
11 pro max
alright then this video will start
according to these chapters over here
first of all you're gonna open any web
browser okay and you're gonna type
figma.com
figma.com like that hit enter
you're gonna find this interface over
here and then you can log in or you can
sign up if you don't have an account
okay so i have an account and i'm gonna
log in over here
like that
i'm gonna use google over here
so once you have signed up you're gonna
find this interface over here okay let
me
explain this in short okay so all of
these are your draft
the projects that you are working on
okay let me actually
scroll down a little bit so that i can
show you some of my projects over here
okay like that
and this one over here do you see this
this is used to create a new draft file
i mean a new project and over here on
this section over here you're gonna find
some templates over here in order to
save your time okay you can scroll down
and see all of these templates over here
as well if you want to download figma
for the desktop version you can do it as
well you're gonna click this over here
on your profile icon okay like that and
then
you're gonna click this get desktop app
and then it's gonna automatically
download sigma for you
all right now i'm gonna show you this
community tab over here okay i'm gonna
click this or what you can do is you can
come over here and you can click this
community over here and it's gonna bring
you over here so so this community tab
contains works of other people so that
you can download and use for your own
purposes okay let me scroll down a
little bit so you're gonna find this so
these are the trending files over here
you're gonna find various assets over
here various design systems okay so look
at this over here these are various
icons that you can download and use for
on your projects
so like that we have tons of resources
published by other people for completely
free all right so i'm gonna scroll down
so that you can look more okay
and then at the very top over here these
these are their filters okay if you want
just plugins if you want to just look at
plugins you can click over here
or perhaps you want to see some
illustrations okay you're gonna click
this illustrations over here
and then you're gonna find various
illustrations various digital assets
okay like that
for instance let's say that look at this
illustration over here if i click over
here
if you want to use this for your project
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
click this duplicate option okay like
this and it's gonna give you a copy to
your figma file
and you can navigate the designs i mean
navigate the assets through these pages
over here okay like the components look
at all of these components over here so
you got this for completely free okay
let me zoom in a little bit so that i
can show you various design assets
and if i want to change the background
color i can also do it by this look at
that
from purple to white like this now look
at my designs over here okay
look at this models over here that i can
use for my projects okay
like this
okay i can zoom in and i can zoom in and
zoom out at various assets over here
like that look at all of these assets
along with those people illustrations i
also get this over here look at this
in order to go back
to your profile from the community tab
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
click over here okay and then you're
gonna click on your profile like this
and you're gonna come back to your
sigma dashboard over here so this is our
practice project i have included a link
in the description down below you click
that and you're gonna come over here
so once you come over here you're gonna
click this duplicate option okay so if
you click on this
duplicate then it's gonna duplicate your
project on your profile like this
first of all let's inspect what we have
on our left panel over here you see this
panel over here so you see these layers
over here this layers represents all of
these layers that we have over here and
this assets over here i'm going to
discuss in details about this one when i
am discussing about the components part
this one over here part number nine all
right i'm gonna come back to layers over
here
and this one represents all my pages
okay so these are all my pages over here
if i click this over here it's gonna
hide my pages if i click it back it's
gonna show me all the pages that i have
if you want to create a new page then
you can click this plus sign over here
and you can name it whatever you want
like i'm gonna name page one over here
like this and i'm gonna hit enter if you
want to delete a page then you can just
right click over here and delete this
like that
or perhaps if you want to rename it then
you can click this over here so i'm
going to delete this okay i don't need
it
so all our designs are arranged into
these pages over here first of all you
have the start button over here i mean
start page over here you can see this so
you can see this thumbnail over here the
topics covered page over here the
breakpoints over here and if i come to
this desktop page you can find the
web design for the desktop version okay
if i click this laptop over here you're
gonna find the design for this
laptop version okay similarly for the
tablet as well this is the design for
the tablet version this is the mobile
version this one is the responsive test
i'm gonna discuss about this part when
i'm discussing the constraints property
this one part number eight i have
included a small sample
on this page over here so that you can
test how prototypes work
in figma
so i'm gonna discuss prototypes in part
number five
and this page the assets page carries
all our assets all our illustrations and
social media icons we're gonna make our
web design using all of these assets
over here and this section the credits
section carries all the links from where
i have downloaded the illustrations okay
so you can see this over here if you
double click over here like this then
you can copy this link and you can go to
that link
and see the original source of the
illustrations all right then i'm back to
the start page over here
and now over here i'm going to create a
new frame okay by the way all our
designs are arranged into frames okay if
i hit f
or if i click this over here this frame
button don't worry i'm gonna discuss in
details about all the tools on this top
panel
and on this right panel over here okay
if i select this frame over here and if
i drag it like this like that okay by
the way regarding the basic movements
you can use your mouse scroll to go top
to bottom like this okay if you hit
shift and scroll your mouse wheel you
can go left to right like this
okay if you hit
ctrl and if you use a mouse scroll then
you can go
zoom in and zoom out like this look at
that
all right
all right then so i'm back over here on
this frame over here all of these i mean
all our elements are arranged into
frames okay let's say that i have a
circle okay i'm gonna hit o and i'm
gonna draw a circle over here like this
look at that and now i'm gonna create a
rectangle okay if i hit r on my keyboard
then i can draw a rectangle over here
like this let's say that i want some
text okay if i hit t on my keyboard and
click over here then i can write text
okay like this ctrl a and you increase
the font size over here to 50.
uh not 50 let's say 200 okay like that
look at that we have some text over here
as well and
so look over here this is our frame okay
and this frame carries all our
elements over here this
this ellipse over here you see this
ellipse it gets highlighted in blue you
can see this blue highlighted color okay
if i highlight the rectangle look at
this i'm selecting the rectangle okay if
i select the text over here like this
look it gets highlighted over here
and do you see these two buttons over
here if i click this then it's gonna
hide me the
frame like this look at that
okay now look at this i can move this
frame anywhere i want okay if i do it
like this look at that but if you want
to
lock the position of this frame what you
can do is you're gonna click this over
here the frame or you can just click on
the name over here you see you see this
frame number 52 i'm gonna click this on
the name and then i'm gonna click this
lock button over here then it's gonna
lock me the position it is it's not
gonna move from its position it's gonna
stay fixed over here including all the
assets that is
carried on the frame
now look i can't select the text i can't
select the shapes over here as well it's
gonna get locked over here in order to
unlock that i'm gonna click this over
here like this unlock now i can move it
and i can select all of these elements
over here as well like that so i'm gonna
delete this frame over here like this
all right now we can keep our content
inside our frame as it is or we can also
arrange them into groups we can group
them directly or we can also use the
auto layout option so if so if i select
all of them over here and if i right
click over here and we can get this
option over here auto layout add auto
layout i'm going to discuss in details
about this tool
on part number seven over here so if i
right click over here then i'm gonna get
this add or layout option
along with that i have this option group
selection if i click on that it's gonna
behave it's gonna behave like a group
okay if i
remove my mouse
and click over here outside this box
then look at this it gets it removes the
blue outline if i click over if i hover
over here look all the elements gets
highlighted which means that it
acts like a group okay so if i want to
ungroup this what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna click over here and ctrl shift j
ctrl shift g like this now look it will
behave individually like that look at
that this is behaving individually this
one is behaving individually there is
one as well
same thing goes for the oral layout
option okay now i'm going to select all
of them again and i'm going to
create a new group over here okay group
selection now look it behaves like a
group okay let's say that you want to
move okay now let's say that you just
want to select the rectangle and nothing
else so in this cases what you have to
do is you can double click on the
rectangle like this
then it's going to select just the
rectangle over here or what you can do
is you can hit ctrl on your keyboard
control and click one time over here
then it's gonna select only the
rectangle if you want just only the text
you're gonna select control on your
keyboard and
just select the text over here like this
or what you have to do is you're gonna
select this whole thing and then double
click over here like this look at that
it's gonna select our text over here
now we're gonna discuss in details about
all the tools that is listed on the top
bar over here this one over here and all
the tools that is listed on the right
side over here so let's get started all
right then the very first thing that i
want to talk about is the movement how
will you move back and forth in your
figma file okay so if you hit
shift and then if you scroll your mouse
will then you can go left and right like
this look at that okay so if you release
this shift and just
use your mouse scroll then what you can
do is you can just
scroll top to the bottom like this look
at that okay so in order to go top to
bottom you're gonna use a mouse scroll
like this okay like that
and if you want to go to left to right
then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna hit shift and then you're gonna
scroll your mouse like that look at that
you're going left to right if you want
to zoom in and zoom out what you're
gonna do is you're gonna hit ctrl and
then you're gonna use your mouse scroll
like this look at that i'm zooming out
and then i'm zooming in like that look
at that
okay and you can also use this hand tool
over here okay if you
hover over here or perhaps you can also
use the h
key on your keyboard like this and then
you can pinch your
left mouse button or you can just click
over here and you can just move back and
forth like this look at that
there we go let's talk about this
feature over here
so if you click over here you have two
options the move option and the scale
option first of all let's look at the
move option okay so if i click this move
option or shortcut v
okay you can
see all the shortcuts over here v for
move and scale it is k okay so i'm gonna
select that
move option over here v okay and then
i'm gonna come over here and then i'm
gonna select this frame in order to
select this frame you're gonna select
this name over here and then
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
move it like this look at that you can
move freely independently anywhere you
want okay you can select any frame you
wish for instance let's say that i want
to select this frame over here okay and
then i'm gonna move it anywhere i want
like this look at that i can move it
like that not just frame you can move
any element okay if you want to move
this image then you can also move it
like this look at that i have selected
this and i'm gonna move it like that
look at that i can move it anywhere i
want
like that
okay control that
in order to make you understand the
scale feature i mean this one even
better first of all we need to look at
the
frame feature this one and the rectangle
feature over here so let's go
all right now i'm gonna come over here
and let's discuss about the frame
feature okay so i'm gonna come over here
and then i'm gonna select this or
shortcut i'm gonna hit f okay f like
this then you're gonna get all of these
options over here okay so do you know
what these are these are your
these are the screen width of various
devices okay so let's say that i want to
work with mobile okay so i'm gonna click
this phone over here and look at this i
have a iphone 11 pro max and then you
see this one over here this measurement
this is the
width and the height of the screen okay
i can also work with iphone 8 iphone se
google pixel 2 etc we have a lot of
options over here but if you don't want
the phone you can also go for the tablet
there we go and if you want to work with
the desktop boom there we go and you can
also you can even also work with
watch
like apple watch over here and then we
have social media
post dimensions over here as well but if
you want to make something custom what
you're gonna do is you're gonna hit f
like this and then click over here like
this and you can uh
drag this little icon over here anywhere
you want and you can just customize the
width and height according to your needs
okay so now
the next thing that i want to talk about
is this one over here okay so what is
this this is a frame okay it's gonna
show me that it is a frame but if you
want to change it if you want to change
the frame to a
custom frame let's say that i want to
work with iphone 11 pro max okay i'm
going to select this now look it's gonna
change me the width and the height like
that look at that but if i want to work
with let's say uh
we have surface pro 4 okay look at this
predefined width and height okay if i
select this then it's gonna give me that
width and height if i select this now
look 1368 by 912 pixels i mean 1368 is
the width
912 is the height like that look at that
and also you can just a drag like this
according to your needs okay you can
adjust the width and height okay so look
at this x and y these are the
coordinates i mean where is your
frame located in your sigma 5 this
x and y represents that if you
drag it like this look at that your
frame is moving to the left i mean to
the right okay if you want to move it to
the left like this then you can also do
it like that there we go
if you want to move it
vertically then you can do it with the y
axis over here like that and if you
don't want that feature then you can
just drag your frame over here and
i mean click your frame over here and
drag anywhere you want
like this look at that
okay let's say that i want to place it
over here okay beside my
offered courses
frame over here like that look at that i
have kept it over here and it's gonna
give me automatic calculations over here
i don't have to worry about that now
let's look at this feature over here the
width and the height okay
you can guess it by the name this is
used to set the width and height of your
frame or perhaps your rectangles as well
or any shapes you want okay so i'm going
to select this so i'm going to select
this like this and look at these
features over here okay i'm going to
select this and i can individually set
the numbers let's say that i want
800 pixels okay i'm gonna write 800
pixels over here there we go it is 800
pixels over here you can also do
mathematical calculations over here as
well let's say that i want to add
another 50 pixels okay i'm going to
write 50 over here now i'm going to hit
enter look at that 850 pixels you can
also do
minus multiplications etc according to
your needs okay i'm gonna let's say i
want to minus nine pixels from here it
is 859 pixels so minus nine enter there
we go 850 by 850 which is a square
okay i changed my mind i'm going to set
it to let's say 350 over here like this
look at that okay so do you know what
mode this is this is the portrait mode
over here
and let's convert it to landscape mode
okay i'm gonna click this over here like
this and do you see these two little
buttons over here this is the portrait
mode and this is the landscape mode look
at this
and look at my first of all look at my
width and height okay the width is 350
height is 650 it's gonna get shifted
between these two okay let me show you
okay i'm gonna select this over here now
look so after selecting this button over
here now look very carefully
the value of these two jumped
it was 650 before and now it's 350 okay
it was 315 hours 650 now look very
carefully i'm gonna
convert it back to portrait okay like
this look at that look at that these two
values are jumping at the same time our
frame is changing over here look at this
there we go like that
if you want to change the angle of a
frame you can just drag over here like
this look at this i can change the angle
of my frame look at this it is rotating
okay i'm let me actually zoom in a
little bit now look at this it will
rotate like this okay we have negative
values we have positive values etcetera
you can just manually do it as well like
this i'm gonna set it to zero like this
there we go boom now look at this over
here this is the corner radius okay uh
look here very carefully i'm gonna zoom
in do you see this this is pointy
corners okay so if i select this and if
i drag like this on the right side now
look
we can set curves
on our shapes and
frames okay so look at this
look very carefully look at this you see
this
okay now let me talk about this one okay
the clip content what this is okay in
order to make you understand this clip
content first of all i'm gonna set some
text over here okay t
or you can just select this option over
here but don't worry i'm gonna explain
in details about this
tool and all of its properties okay it
is coming wait a minute okay i'm gonna
click over here and then click over here
like this look and i'm gonna select some
text oh it's very big okay so i'm gonna
uh what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna uh
select over here okay 180 pixels i'm
going to set it to 60 over here like
this look at that adf okay
oh sorry sidf okay just some random text
okay
i just place some random text over here
like this look at that
abc
abc
makes more sense okay so now look what
happens okay i'm gonna remove that clip
content from here okay
look nothing is
set over here okay now look what i what
happens if i resize it like this look at
this
okay the text is outside
the text is outside and the frame
is getting resized like this look at
that
okay
you can clearly see the content
even if we
resize our
frame you can see that you can clearly
see the content even if we resize our
frame even if the frame is smaller than
the content but look very carefully what
happens if i enable the clip content
over here like this look at that
it gets clipped like a scissor okay now
if i resize it now you can visibly see
all the parts of our
content over here okay like that look at
that
now let me explain this feature over
here do you see this feature
resize to fit now look what happens if i
click this okay
there we go it resizes i mean it removes
all the gaps and adjusts to our content
there's one over here this is very
useful when we are making buttons
let me give you an example okay control
z let's say that i'm going to make a
button okay b you t o n like this and
i'm gonna um
make it a smaller let's say uh 30 pixels
okay and now look
and look instead of doing this one like
this manually like this you have to do a
lot of work over here and then center it
over here like this and then it is
called a button over here like that
instead of doing this hard work what you
can do is control that that said that it
means i mean going i mean i'm going back
okay by doing ctrl z
like this look at that so what you can
do is simply you just click on your
frame and then you click this over here
resize to fit there we go boom we made
ourselves a button
this is just a sample on how to create a
button but after a couple of minutes i'm
going to discuss in details how to make
a button using auto layout i mean this
one over here with appropriate
calculations
so wait a couple of minutes so once
that's done i can adjust the corners
over here like this look at that
there we go like that i can adjust the
corners and then i can rotate it over
here like this look at that
okay ctrl set
and regarding the corner right yes look
at this i have this corner i mean i have
set it to 8 pixels which means that it's
gonna set eight pixel over here eight
pixels here here here let's say that i
don't want uh the corner radius to be on
the right side i just want it to be on
the left side just one single side so
what can we do in this scenario i'm
gonna select this over here and i'm
gonna click this little icon over here
okay and then look at this this is
called
independent corners it is set to eight
pixels for all the four corners okay so
let's say that i don't want the corner
radius on the right side i just want it
on the left side so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna do it like this okay this is
the top
this is the top left
okay this is the top right i'm gonna
select this and i'm gonna set it to zero
like this look at that now look the
corner effect is removed okay i'm gonna
select this again and i'm gonna select
um
top left top right
bottom left bottom right this one okay
i'm gonna select this zero oh i actually
sorry my bad i
chose the wrong corner over here but you
learn from mistakes right so i'm gonna
select this again and i'm gonna set it
to eight pixels over here and zero over
here like this and then enter look at
that i have corner radius over here on
the left side not on the right side
there we go
now let's discuss about this feature
okay the slice feature so what this is
used is um let me actually come to my uh
let me actually delete this okay
i'm gonna come on to this frame over
here okay let's say that i just want not
the whole image i just want the head
okay i just want to download the head i
just want to work with the head okay so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna click
this over here slice okay and then i'm
gonna
draw a rectangle over here on the head
section can you see this properly okay
there we go now look i have a little
slice over here you can see this okay
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
select the slice over here either from
here
or i can directly select it here okay
and then i can adjust the width and
height as well like this look at that
all right
and i can also move it like this look at
that there we go and then i'm gonna
click it over here and then can you see
this export button over here i'm gonna
click this export which means i'm
downloading this okay i'm gonna click
this plus sign over here and you can set
the image quality as well you can set it
to png jpg svg i'm gonna do it in svg
okay i'm gonna select this and then i'm
gonna export this one look at this i
have downloaded a little file over here
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna drag
it over here like this
look at this i just
look at this over here i just download
it i mean i just
slice the head
because i just only need to work with
the head okay now look look at this this
is equal to this one over here this
slice over here i hope you understood
the slice property
now regarding this export button you can
download anything you want okay let me
actually give you a demo okay i'm gonna
delete this from here and at the same
time i'm going to remove this slice from
here as well and let's say that um i
want to download this single frame over
here okay just single frame or perhaps
even just the drawing over here i'm in
the illustration i just want to download
the illustration and nothing else or you
can also download multiple files as well
by clicking by clicking this one and
then shift then click like this then
click like this as well now let's say
for keeping this simple i'm gonna
download this image okay i'm gonna click
this over here and then i'm gonna scroll
down at the bottom over here and then
look at this i have the export button
i'm gonna click over here and then look
at this
you can change the size as well you can
download it two times three times or
four times the actual size okay and then
we have the png svg jpg pdf etc formats
okay you can download it anywhere you
want i mean i mean you can download you
can download it in any format you want
and then you're gonna hit the export
frame button
and here this feature this preview
option is given just to let you know
that what you are downloading okay you
can see this i have just selected this
frame i mean this illustration over here
let's say that i want to select this
text over here okay i'm gonna select
this text and i'm gonna select this
export like this and look at that it is
giving it is giving me this preview that
i am just downloading the text over here
now let's discuss about the shape
feature okay so i'm gonna come over here
you see this shape
it looks like a square okay i'm gonna
select this like this look at this i
have a lot of options i have rectangle
line arrow ellipse polygon etc let's say
that i want a polygon sorry i want an
ellipse okay i'm gonna click this or i
can select o
so i'm gonna select o like this and look
at this i can make a circle over here
but look this circle looks distorted and
it's gonna be very hard for me to make a
perfect circle so in this case what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna select i mean i'm
gonna hit shift
now look it instantly became a perfect
circle and now while
holding shift i can just move my mouse
and look it's gonna give me a perfect
circle like this look at that okay this
is a perfect circle over here i'm gonna
delete this
and i have more options like a rectangle
okay
and i'm gonna select a rectangle like
this look at that okay i can do it
anywhere i want i mean i can move it
anywhere i want and i can select the
width and height accordingly okay look
at this i'm moving this and i'm resizing
this like this
and do you see this little dot over here
this dot this dot dot dot over here it
is used to set the radius look at this
corner radius you can do it over here or
you can
you can do it over here directly like
this or what you can do is you can
select this options over here okay like
this as i told you a little bit earlier
okay you can do it like this as well
and yeah do you remember the scale
button i mean do you remember the scale
tool over here this one as i told you
that i'm gonna discuss in details after
discussing this frame and this rectangle
now i'm gonna discuss this okay so what
where this scale button is used let's
say that um you want to scale i mean you
want something let's say that you want
to make something bigger okay so in the
case of the circle uh do you remember
the circle this distorted circle okay
look at this you cannot make it a
perfect circle let's say that i have
selected the shift okay shift now look
it looks like a perfect circle okay i
have released that shift now let's say
that you want to make it a little bigger
okay what you normally do is you're
gonna select this like this look at this
okay when you try to make it bigger it's
gonna get distorted again so in this
case what you can do is you can just i
simply select the shift and it's gonna
resize accordingly or what you can do is
you can select this scale function over
here you can select this over here
directly or you can just select the k
option on your keyboard okay k and look
at this i have a different icon on my
mouse okay i'm gonna select v which
means
move okay look at this
icon on my mouse okay i'm gonna zoom in
a little bit look at this this is v this
is for the move this is the default and
if i want to resize
this is k look at this scale and this is
move okay i'm gonna give k over here
like this now i'm gonna resize look it's
gonna resize proportionately in
proportional measurements okay now look
at this okay 788 by 788 okay i'm gonna
resize it again now look at that it's
gonna give me accurate proportion
measurements
so i'm gonna remove this circle from
here and i'm gonna draw a perfect square
okay shift and then
oh sorry i'm gonna
hit r which means rectangle or you can
just select it from here as well and
shift and then drag like this look at
this this is a perfect square okay now
let's talk about this feature this fill
feature okay this is used to color your
rectangle i mean color your shapes like
this look at that you can color it
anything you wish you can also put input
the hex value you can also change the
opacity over here you can also uh use
this predefined colors let's say that i
want to use sky blue over here look at
that and you can also use this dropper
tool okay if you select this dropout
tool then you can uh select anything you
wish let's say that i want
my box i mean my square to be
the color of this okay so i have this
eye dropper on my hand i'm gonna select
this over here like this now look at my
square over here look this is the same
color as this one over here
now let's look at more features that we
have on our right panel over here okay
this features okay i'm gonna select it
over here and i'm gonna change it to the
default color okay wait a minute e4 e4
e4 like this oh sorry
there we go it is c4 c4 c4 all right so
the first thing that i want to discuss
is the stroke so what this does is it
gives a stroke around our box okay let
me show you okay okay i'm gonna select
this like this look at that it's gonna
generate me a little stroke over here
okay can you see this black colored
outline over here i'm gonna uh
increase its weight okay like this look
three four five six seven eight nine ten
so the stroke is ten pixels okay can you
see this black color thick stroke over
here you can also change the various
properties like the color the size then
should it be inside the box or should it
be on the center or should it be outside
the box like that look at that you can
also hide the shadow i mean you can also
hide the stroke like this if you select
this i button over here like that look
at that you can also click it over here
again and it's going to show me
the stroke over here and if you want to
remove this stroke permanently you can
also use this minus button over here
like this look at that it went away
okay now we're going to look at this
effects feature okay for that i'm gonna
just um resize this little bit like that
okay now if i select this effect button
look at this i have this panel over here
okay i have a lot of options like if i
want to make a drop shadow or if i want
some layer blur or perhaps background
blur
we have inner shadow as well for now i'm
going to show you the drop shadow okay
i'm going to select this over here and
yes you can experiment on your own and
look at this i have a little bit of
shadow do you see this shadow at the
back of this
rectangle let me actually remove that
shadow okay look at this do you see the
do you see the shadow over there okay i
am hiding the shadow now let me bring
that shadow back look at this so this so
this drop shadow is used to make shadows
to our shapes frames buttons cards etc
all right
so now look at this over here this is
called the effect setting okay so i'm
gonna click over here and then i can
adjust the shadow okay so this is the x
which means that my
shadow will move left and right like
this look at that okay look at this look
my shadow is moving left and right if i
want to
if i want to move the shadow top to the
bottom like this i'm going to use this y
button over here okay like that look at
that and then if i want the shadow to
spread i'm going to use this spread over
here like that look
look the shadow is getting bigger okay
and smaller as well and you can also
change the color over here opacity over
here as well and if you want to change
the blur you can do it like this there
we go we're increasing the blur so we're
gonna equalize this drop shadow when we
are making buttons okay let me actually
give you a demo look at this our buttons
have a little bit of drop shadow over
here as well as these cards look at
these cards okay this has drop shadow so
when we are making this layout i mean
when we are doing this design
we are going to utilize this drop shadow
whatever i have discussed so far this is
the design section okay on the right
panel so this is the prototype over here
after a couple of minutes i am going to
discuss about this prototype okay so
don't worry and look at this inspect
over here okay so if i go to the inspect
then it's gonna generate me css code
let's say that i want the code of this
one okay this section over here then i'm
gonna select this over here and look at
this it is generating this css over here
like this look at that if you are a
developer you can save time
look at this display flex flex direction
column justify content center align
items flex start so on and so forth
along with all of this look pixel
measurements over here along with the
padding
width height etcetera
so this inspect tool is very handy
all right now i'm going to discuss in
details about all of these tools over
here these are the alignment tools okay
so in order to discuss about that i'm
going to come over here and i'm gonna
draw a frame okay f and then i'm gonna
drag it like this look at that okay so
now i'm gonna uh
write some text okay t and then click
over here and then some text over here
okay like that okay let me actually
write abcd okay abcd like that ctrl a
capital letter a
um
a
a b c d there we go now let's say that i
want this text to be at the very center
so what will we do okay so if you come
over here look at this align horizontal
center if i click over here like this
now look our text is at the very center
horizontally okay if i want it to be at
the very center vertically i mean if i
want it to be at the very center over
here so what i'm gonna what am i gonna
click i'm gonna click over here look at
this this is the align vertical centers
like this look at that it is at the very
center both horizontal and vertically
let's say that i want to move it to the
very left at the very left okay what i'm
going to do is i'm going to click this
over here like this look at that this is
alignment left if you want alignment
right you can also do it like this
this option over here like this look at
that
so you can experiment with all of these
values over here
and regarding this i'm going to delete
this over here like this real quick and
regarding this panel over here i'm in
this
tool over here and regarding this text
this is the file name okay if you double
click over here then you can rename it
okay so i'm going to keep it sigma file
over here i'm gonna fill my tutorial
over here like that as it is and if you
click over here like this you can
download this sigma file you can also
duplicate it you can rename it and you
can also delete this as well so these
are the options that you have you can
also share it with your friends that
what you created so far like you created
these frames over here if you want to
share it with your friends or perhaps if
you want to share it with your clients
then you can click the share option over
here and then you're going to find
appropriate details okay so i'm going to
remove this now right now and okay now
regarding this button over here this is
called a present button so if you click
on here then you can see your designs
live at the same time if you're working
with prototype then you can also view
your i mean you can also test the
interactivity of your prototypes live
don't worry i'm gonna discuss this
prototype after a couple of minutes okay
so let's say that i'm gonna click on
here okay after selecting this design
over here okay i'm gonna click this
i can view this over here
now look at this this is the desktop
typography okay and if i um come over
here if i click this arrow over here
then it is going to go next like this
wait a minute
these are the sections look at this this
is my design over here okay i can view
it over here
now look this is very large okay i want
to make it small so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna come to this options and then
i'm gonna
i'm gonna select this fit
scale down to fit okay like this there
we go
now now it looks much better okay so i'm
going to come over here and i'm going to
go next or perhaps you can also use it
arrow right like this look at that it's
going to move to the next frame like
this so by this way you can preview your
designs what you created so far okay you
can view it like this look at that there
we go
now we're going to discuss about the
text tool in details
so this tool over here the text tool is
used to add text to our web designs so
if you notice carefully that every
design the desktop tablet
laptop mobile contains this chart over
here okay this is the typography guide
chart shows that what should be the font
size of the logo the font size of the
nav items
font size of the large text font size of
the small text the text of the button
etc along with the line height over here
so you can see that the line height of
large should be 90 and the line height
of small should be 43 over here same
goes for the mobile design as well look
at this over here i have included the
mobile typography over here so logo this
the logo is 48 pixels then large text 32
button is
24 pixels so on and so forth it also
this chart is also mentioned for the
laptop as well so look at this over here
this is the laptop design over here and
this one is a typography for the laptop
design okay so logo is 60 pixels the
button should be 30 pixels so on and so
forth so i'm going to come over here and
um over here i'm going to create either
a rectangle or a frame so you can
so you can hit r like this and it's
going to create me a rectangle but i'm
gonna use a frame over here okay ctrl z
so if if you hit f like this it's gonna
create a frame like this look at that
okay i'm gonna make the frame a little
smaller um let's say um 1000
by 500 okay that will do for this
tutorial like this look at that all
right then in order to use the text tool
you directly click over here like this
and it's gonna highlight blue over here
and you're gonna get a plus sign on your
mouse can you see my mouse over here it
is in plus sign okay
and
if you want to do it in shortcut way you
just hit t on your keyboard like this t
and it's gonna highlight that text over
here on your mouse and if you click
anywhere then you can
get this sign over here you see this
then you can add text like this look at
that it is set to 110 pixels but by
default your text should be
12 pixels like this which means that uh
wait a minute it should be on 12 pixels
like this which means that it's gonna be
very small so what you're gonna do
you're gonna click over here okay
and you see this
option over here this is used to set the
font size so what is the font size of
our desktop let's see
it is um for the logo it's 90 pixels
okay so let's say to 90 pixels
like this look it is set to 12 i'm gonna
set 90 over here like this okay
then enter and then it's gonna output me
this result okay so this is used to set
the font size
and this one you see this this is used
to set the font family it is kind of set
to roboto and if i click over here and i
can change the fonts family as well like
this it should be uh let's say we're
gonna set it to pop-ins like this
p-o-p-p-i-n-s
pop-ins okay now look the font family
changes
similarly i can also write sans save
over here sans
uh
let's go for sensation okay i'm gonna
hit enter like this look at that it
changed and if you click this drop down
icon over here like this then you have
tons of options of for fonts you can
pick any font family you want like this
look at that so i'm going to set it to
pop-ins like this
p p i n s poppings like that and i'm
gonna name over here edu
dot io like this okay because we're
gonna deal with this logo after all okay
so now the next thing that i'm gonna
show you is this one okay this is the
font weight it is kind of set to re it
is currently set to regular you can also
set extra light over here like this look
at that the font weight changes okay you
can also set it set it to thin like this
look at that it became thin you can also
set it to let's say extra bold look at
that how bold this text is okay i hope
you understood it so far and you see
this over here so this is used to set
the line height look at that it is
written highlighted over there line
height okay so i'm gonna set it to let's
say regular okay like this so i'm this
logo should be regular and in order to
text in i'm in order to test this line
height you cannot just simply
test with just a single line you need
multiple lines okay so i'm gonna delete
it over here like this and i'm gonna
drag um this one this text you see this
text over here i'm gonna drag it to our
test case so in order to drag it so what
you're gonna do is you're gonna control
you're gonna hit ctrl okay and then just
pick this text over here like this and
then i'm gonna zoom out and i'm gonna
click the alt i'm gonna select the alt
text like this alt and you see
my mouse is getting
a little shadow on its back
like two mouse together okay so i'm
gonna select the alt text and i'm gonna
move my mouse like this look at that it
is getting copied okay i'm gonna come
over here and
don't move okay just first of all just
release your mouse click like this okay
and then you're gonna release the alt
key like this look now we have
successfully copied our text on here
okay
now look at this now now we're gonna
come over here and we're gonna select
this like this and then we're gonna see
this okay look at here the line height
is set to 43
and if you want to change it then you're
going to click over here or you can
directly you can directly put the number
over here like this let's say i want to
set it to 110 pixels like this okay if i
click enter now look it has 100 tilt 110
pixels of gap over here let's say that i
want to set it to um
20 okay you can directly input it over
here like this 20. look at that it
became very
congested like this okay so if you click
over here you see this i got a small
icon okay arrow sign icon like this i'm
gonna move my mouse like this now look i
can practice with this real time like
this without worrying about i mean
without directly inputting the value
over there okay look at that i'm just
playing around i'm just playing around
with my mouse so that i can find that
sweet spot which would be
ideal which would be the ideal line
height okay so i'm going to change it to
43 like that because it is actually
given on the style guide over here um
wait a minute over here look at that the
small text it should be 30 pixels
and look at this
the line height should be 43 pixels okay
um i'm gonna come over here like this
and look at this the
the font size is 30 over here and
it is set to poppins and the line height
is 43 over here now do you say this over
here this is called the letter spacing
so line height works like this okay but
the later spacing letter spacing works
like this
it's gonna put gap between our little
like this okay i'm gonna show you okay
i'm gonna keep it over here like this
and watch very carefully by the way you
can also input direct value over here
like this uh 30 over here like this then
it's going to be 30
or perhaps you can also set this i mean
you can also use this mouse over here
and you're gonna get this little um
arrow sign okay so i'm gonna drag like
this look at that it's gonna change
according to my mouse
movement okay look at that
like this it's working like that so this
is used to set the letter spacing i hope
you understood it so far i'm gonna set
it to zero over here like this now look
at this one
this is called the paragraph spacing
okay in case if you have multiple
paragraphs then this is going to work
okay so if i drag like this over here
then you can see this behavior it is
working like a line height but it should
not work like a line height because i
have actually used some gap over here
like this let me actually show you wait
a minute i'm gonna set it to default
control z control set again like that
okay so what is
happening is i have given some line
break over here that's why it is
behaving like a paragraph but if i uh
set it to its original state like this
wait a minute just give me a second okay
it is actually the original state look
at this long text over here okay now i'm
going to shrink it like this look at
this okay i'm gonna shrink it like this
and it's gonna behave like this okay let
me actually zoom in uh there we go i
hope you can see this my i hope you can
see my screen okay i'm gonna look at
this this is behaving just
like a single paragraph okay now look
now look what happens if i use it okay
now look it is not working the paragraph
spacing is not working this will only
work when you have multiple paras okay
let me actually show you okay i'm gonna
copy this one over here like this let's
say two lines okay ctrl c and then i'm
going to paste it over here like this
ctrl v there we go so how many pairs do
we have we have two pairs now look at
this uh paragraph height
i'm in paragraph spacing okay it is 23
pixels i'm gonna drag my mouse like this
look at that i can change that paragraph
spacing but look it's it's it is set to
zero but there is some gap over here
that is the gap of your line height look
at that okay you can also write over
here but if you remove that white space
from here then look it's gonna work like
that now look it is set to zero
exact zero okay i'm gonna drag it over
here like this now look it is working
perfectly fine there we go
let's look at the next feature okay i'm
gonna click over here and look at this
do you see this
this is the text align left text align
center text align right okay let's
experiment okay so i'm gonna drag it i
mean i'm gonna drag the window like this
okay over here like this look at that
now look the text is behaving on the
left side okay text align left now i'm
gonna change to center okay you see this
third line over here look at that it is
set to left now it's gonna move to the
middle like this okay if i click over
here like this text align center now
look
it is changing the alignment the text
alignment is changing to center like
this and i have also the option of right
over here look at that
right text and right so if you want to
if you want the option of justify you're
gonna click this little icon over here
okay wait a minute you're gonna click
this little icon over here and then
you're gonna find this justify over here
which means that it's gonna
appropriately i mean equally distribute
the spaces in a way that it fills the
whole
box over here okay so let me actually
make this para into a line like this now
look at that you see this one this line
over here and this line over here look
the text are equally distributed inside
the box so that it looks like text align
justified all right
so i hope you understood this alignment
tools over here now look at this tool
over here okay or a width or a height
and then fixed size so
so in order to discuss these tools over
here first of all what you're going to
do is you're going to um
reduce the size of your phone size okay
so i'm going to set it to let's say um
let's say uh 20 20 pixels like this
okay now let's say i'm i want to drag it
like this okay i'm gonna drag that box
like that now look this is behaving like
a fixed height which means that our para
over here will occupy
uh what is this 912
pixels of width into
286 pixels of height
so it's gonna occupy that much amount of
space in on our web design or perhaps on
our on our frame okay so i can uh drag
it like this now look it's gonna i mean
those snapping guides okay you see this
orange colors colored guide over here
it's gonna work accordingly to our box i
mean the box which carries the text okay
so
this is how the fixed height i mean
fixed size works but if you snap it to
or a width which means that it's gonna
hug the content inside the box so that
there is no additional spaces look at
this you see this box over here along
with the blue colored guides okay so i'm
going to click over here which is or a
width now look at that
it's going to work as if it is a single
line first of all and the next thing is
it's not gonna keep any additional gaps
okay so let's say that um
i want to break the line okay i want to
break the line over here like this so
you can also do it you can also break
the line like that
there we go it's gonna work like that
and if i let's say for any instance this
changes to like this okay it's gonna
let's say that it changed to this so
what you're gonna do is if you want to
reduce those white spaces normally most
of the people what they do is they're
gonna do it like this look
they're gonna do it like this but this
will not give you exact measurements i
mean it's not the ideal scenario so what
you're gonna use is you're gonna use
this little icon over here which is auto
auto width okay the auto height um wait
a minute this auto height works in a
similar manner okay it just works with
the height okay i'm gonna click over
here and if i select this then it's
gonna automatically snap those height
and remove those white space from my
text like that okay now let's look at
these tools over here these three tools
over here okay this is
align top align at the middle and align
at the bottom okay let's say that i have
this text and i'm gonna resize it like
this okay now look i have a lot of space
inside my rectangle and where is my text
where is my text aligned it is aligned
at the top very top if i want to take it
on the middle like this okay i can use
this one over here like this look at
that it's gonna come to the middle
inside this box
and let's say that i want to take my um
text at the very center okay what i'm
gonna use is i'm gonna use this little
icon over here align bottom like that
like that look at that it has aligned it
has aligned to the bottom
so let's change it back like this
at the top and then our weight like this
there we go
now let's look at this tools over here
okay you see these three dots over here
if you select this like this then you're
gonna have more tools okay first of all
you're gonna get this alignment tools
over here and then the decorations okay
so if you hover over here then you're
gonna get live preview what each and
every tool does like this look at this
underline tool it's gonna underline my
text okay if i select this like this
you're gonna not only see the result
over here live look at that look at this
little screen okay you can also see the
result over here okay like that so i'm
gonna click it over here as well so if i
want to remove the decoration then i'm
gonna select this over here like this
none then you can also um strike through
the text like this you have a lot of
options if you want to make lists look
at this list option over here okay if i
click this then it's going to create me
a list okay unordered list and if you
want to make it to ordered list then you
can click this over here and order list
in one two three so on and so forth so
if you want paragraph indentation you
can utilize this feature okay wait a
minute this paragraph indentation
feature okay so if you um say to let's
say 30 pixels like this okay oh this is
actually not working that's because we
have multiple line breaks so i'm gonna
uh make it just a single line like this
wait a minute just give me a second and
then i'm gonna
drag this
inside my frame okay wait a second like
that there we go and it is just working
like a single paragraph and then oral
height like this i mean auro wait like
this okay oh i did it in the wrong way
my bad sorry okay now looks good now
look i have some paragraph indentation
at the very
first of the text okay look at this we
have 30 pixels we have 30 pixels of gap
over here if you want to increase the
gap let's say um a hundred let's go for
100 okay 100 like this there we go we
have 100 pixels of gap over here
let's look at more options that we have
okay so we have the letter case over
here okay this is the default i mean the
way you write it's gonna be default okay
so if you want all the text to be
capital sized okay you have this upper
case okay now look at this text okay
lorem ipsum
dollar set okay it is in small text
lowercase letter okay i'm going to
change it to uppercase letter okay i'm
going to click over here and then i'm
going to click this okay it is also
preview
it's going to give me preview over here
as well okay so i'm going to click this
over here now look all the text all
letter has changed to upper
uppercase letters okay like this look at
that you can also change it to lowercase
letters by clicking this okay look at
that all the texts are i mean all the
letters are lowercase
by the way if you want to change the
color of your text what you have to do
is you're gonna select any text okay
let's say that i want to select this
text over here okay so i'm gonna what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna control and
then click over here like this okay or
what you can do is you can double click
over here like this and it's gonna get
selected okay okay
and then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna scroll down over here and you see
this fill option over here you can still
change the color over here by inputting
your hex value over here or what you can
do is you can just select this option
over here okay you can get this
eyedropper over here which means that
you can pick any color you want like
this look i'm going to select this over
here like this and let's say that i want
to change it to
this color over here okay so i'm going
to select this and look the text gets
colored according to this color over
here
similarly what you can do is you can
drag this little uh
small dot over here and you can place
anywhere you want and the color changes
accordingly okay i'm gonna
move this ball over here and you're
gonna
see the changes over here okay look at
this i'm gonna change it to black let's
say i want to
i'm gonna change it to black let's say
like this okay and let's say i want to
change it to white okay i'm gonna go
over here like this by the way you can
also move this over here just change the
color okay let's say i want to go to red
okay i'm gonna come to red over here and
this palette over here turns to red okay
i can move it over here as well like
this look at that if you want to change
the opacity then you can change it over
here like this look i'm gonna
look i'm gonna drag this slider over
here and look at this effect over here
okay it's gonna get changed okay look at
this i'm gonna drag it and look the
opacity changes okay if i turn it to
zero it's gonna be invisible okay if i
if i go to absolute zero like this then
it's gonna get invisible okay
so ladies and gentlemen we're done
discussing the text tool along with all
its properties
as a beginner you don't have to
understand prototypes
so this is the feature that i'm
discussing right now the prototype over
here this one okay
but for the sake of this tutorial and to
make you understand
how and where the prototype feature is
used i have created a small section over
here on this pages okay so you can see
this prototype sample you're gonna come
over here okay now you can see two
designs over here okay this is the
mobile design now let me tell you where
prototype is used prototype is used to
make interactive web designs so i have
kept an example over here on this
section okay prototype sample
so now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
click over here okay prototype like this
now look
i already created some frames over here
but i'm gonna delete it okay so i'm
gonna click it over here like this
and i'm gonna delete and then i'm gonna
click over here and then delete okay so
i'm starting i'm starting from scratch
in order to make one sorry so i'm
starting from scratch in order to make
you understand how the system works i
mean the prototype how prototype works
so first of all let's understand this
model over here okay so this is our nav
bar over here and this is the hamburger
menu icon over here okay so the moment
we click this
menu icon over here okay it's gonna get
converted to this cross sign over here
and then this content over here will get
vanished and then it's gonna
show us our
menu items over here like home teacher
so on and so forth etc
in order to create a prototype what
you're gonna do is you're gonna click
over here okay this section prototype
like that and you're gonna get this
instructions over here okay
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is i'm gonna select this okay by double
clicking over here
like that look at that i have selected
this hamburger menu icon okay so look at
this do you see this plus sign over here
it means that
the moment we click on here or the
moment we tap on here where do we where
will this lead us to okay it's gonna
lead us to this frame over here i mean
this
design over here okay so i'm gonna click
and drag this one like this look at this
arrow on my hand okay i'm gonna drag it
like this over here there we go so this
is getting linked to this one over here
all right
and then it's gonna give me this option
over here so look at this interaction
details that popped up okay so it's
telling me it's asking me
how this
interaction should take place okay
should it be on click or on drag all
while hovering while pressing
then we have mouse and we have a lot of
options over here to pick from but but
for this tutorial i'm gonna keep it very
simple okay on click which means that
the moment we click this one over here
then it's gonna show us this frame over
here okay
and then
we also need to click over here so that
we can go back to this main content over
here so how do we do this we're gonna do
the same thing okay we're gonna double
click over here on this cross sign and
then you see this little plus over here
let me zoom in you see this little plus
over here we're gonna select that and
drag it back to this main frame over
here like this look at that there we go
and then it's also gonna show me this
interaction designs i mean interaction
details okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna keep it as it is and then look at
this
animation over here so i'm gonna click
over here so instead of instant i'm
gonna select dissolve over here like
that so you have a bunch of i mean a lot
of options to choose from but i'm gonna
keep it very simple just dissolve okay
like that and i'm gonna select this one
as well and i'm gonna set the animation
to dissolve as well like that look at
that now look in order to test this
prototype what you have to do is you're
gonna click this play button over here
do you see this play button over here
i'm gonna click it like this now let's
experiment it's gonna create me a new
window over here okay and
there we go look at this our design is
over here i mean this is our prototype
over here okay now look at this look at
my mouse over here wherever wherever i
go it is just a mouse okay but wherever
but whenever i come over here look at
this it's gonna turn into a pointer
which means that this is clickable if i
click over here then it's gonna give me
some animations or interactions okay now
look i'm gonna test it over here like
this okay i'm gonna click like this look
at that look at that we have our
navigation menu items over here and we
also have this cross sign over here okay
i'm gonna click over here again like
that look at that it went back to our
frame mainframe over here let's
experiment again okay click like this
there we go and then in order to go back
look at that do you see this animation
this dissolve animation look at that it
is just fading in fading out i really
hope that you understood the prototype
feature if you want to experiment with
the prototype you're going to come to
this section over here the prototype
sample and follow the instructions that
i have given you
now we are going to discuss about the
feature called our layout
today i'm gonna show you two use cases
how to use the auto layout first of all
i'm gonna show you how to align your
content this content over here this text
this text this button at the same time
i'm gonna show you how to make this
button over here using the auto layout
so now you're gonna come over here like
this and we're gonna create a new frame
over here okay so you hit f like this on
your keyboard okay and then you're gonna
drag it like this look at that we have
created ourselves a new frame okay let
me actually resize it a little bit like
this look at that okay it looks quite
good and then now i'm gonna create a
text okay so t and then i'm gonna place
it over here like this okay i'm gonna
write something like this and then i'm
gonna set the size to let's say 60
pixels okay
wait a minute uh it's gonna work right
now 16 there we go and now i'm gonna
duplicate this okay let's say that i
want to duplicate it uh three times okay
i'm gonna select the keyboard named alt
okay and then i'm gonna drag it like
this look at that okay it's gonna get
copied okay alt and then use your mouse
like this look at that alt and then
mouse it's gonna duplicate me the same
thing okay controls that now
where is the aura layout used let's say
that this text are over here like this
look at that okay in this array let's
say that i want to align them to the
very left or exact measurements how why
i mean look at this over here you see
this
text
one two and and then this button over
here you see all of these elements are
aligned to this box this blue colored
box over here on the very left on exact
accurate measurements so if we want to
copy this layout over here like this
then what we generally have to do is we
have to individually select this element
okay and then we have to take the help
of this guides over here do you see this
orange colored guide that is showing me
the number of gaps 57 pixels okay if i
come over here like this look at this
the orange color guide is getting
highlighted okay let me show you again
okay look at this okay now look this is
on accurate
left align left okay and then if i drag
it over here like this now look it's
gonna get aligned to the left according
to this size over here okay and then
let's say that i want to decrease the
size over here okay i'm gonna select it
like this okay i'm gonna do it like this
and it get got decreased reduced in size
and let's say that i want to decrease it
even further okay i'm gonna remove this
letters from here like this look at that
okay
now let's say that i want to change the
gap in between this content okay it's
gonna be a hassle okay you have to just
individually take your mouse and then
you have to place it like this and if
you want to calculate the space what you
have to do is you're gonna click any
element let's say that i want to click
this element okay this element and then
i'm gonna select my alt key on my
keyboard like this and then wherever i
place my mouse it's gonna show me that
calculation like look at this the
distance between these two elements okay
is 51 pixels look at this orange colored
guide it is highlighting 51 pixels
similarly let's say that i want to
select this and calculate the gap
between these two content okay i'm gonna
select alt and then i'm gonna put a
mouse on this content look at this 39
pixels this is how it works but it's
gonna be a long hassle if you do it
manually so in this case what you can
use is the oral layout okay let me
actually show you okay
so i'm gonna click all of them together
and then i'm gonna right click like this
and look at this option auto add auto
layout okay i can do it over here like
this or do you see this option
shortcut key shift a you can also
press the shift a and it's going to work
okay like this look at that okay now
look if i
so if you notice on the right side you
see this new section over here this is
called the aural layout okay if you want
to remove the auto layout then you're
gonna select this minus over here okay
and then it's gonna remove it and
convert it back to a frame how do you
know when it gets converted to a frame
okay you're gonna actually you're gonna
show you're gonna see on the right side
okay look at this okay this hashtag this
hashtag means the frame now if you go
back by selecting ctrl z like this um
look at this over here wait a minute
look at this we have
two rows like this i mean two lines like
this this represents the oral layout
okay now let's look at the options that
we have okay so uh i'm gonna select this
like this and it's gonna highlight me
that auto layout okay look at this i
have 45 pixels of gap in between each of
this content okay so if i drag my mouse
like this look at that the amount of
gap in between this content changes okay
like this look at that okay lowest is
zero and upper limit is anything you
wish okay like this let's say i want to
set it to um 25 pixels like this look at
that and this one look at this one this
is used to add padding around your
content okay let me show you okay i'm
going to select this and drag it like
this look at that look at this
padding is getting added all around my
content like this look at that if you
want to change it again like this look
padding is getting applied like that
now let's talk about this feature over
here padding and alignment okay so if i
uh let's say that i want to uh increase
my size of my content okay like this
look at this i'm gonna drag my blue
colored box like this and it's gonna
increase in size let's say that i want
to place my content at the very center
how do i do this in order to do it
quickly easily efficiently we're gonna
use this tool alignment and padding okay
i'm gonna select this like this and look
at this i have so many options i can
select it anyway i can place it anywhere
i want so our criteria is we have to set
it at the very center how do we do it
we're gonna click this over here you see
this over here option look at that it
got centered on our box over here okay
so let's say that i want to select this
i mean i want to place it on this corner
over here on this corner over here we
can do it so you're gonna select this
like this look at that
it's gonna get
moved to this section over here and do
you see this over here this is the
padding this is used to add padding so
remember this one okay let me actually
uh change it to the default
uh
like that there we go so do you remember
this it's gonna add padding to all four
sides but you don't want this behavior
you just want to add padding to let's
say that left and right okay in order to
do it manually you're gonna click this
over here and you see this option over
here you're gonna manually add padding
over here let's say that um
i want to add 50 pixels of padding to
the left side
there we go boom it's going to add
padding to just to the left side okay
now let's see that now let's say that i
want to add padding to the top okay top
how much uh let's say that 25 pixels
okay so i'm gonna come over here and
write 25 like this and hit enter now
look i have 25 pixels of padding at the
top 50 pixels of padding on the left if
you want to individually set the padding
this tool is very helpful
all right then now let's experiment how
to make a button using the auto layout
okay so i'm gonna delete this from here
okay i'm gonna make a button like this
look at that you see this button over
here i'm gonna make it i mean i'm gonna
duplicate it okay so i'm gonna come over
here and the very first thing that i can
do uh is i'm gonna write text over here
like this okay i'm gonna write after
selecting t and let me show you the
steps okay you're gonna hit t on your
keyboard or you're gonna select this
over here okay so t like this and then
and click over here on your screen i
mean on your frame okay and you're gonna
write button
be your tto and like this button okay so
i'm gonna convert this button text to
full capital letters okay so i'm gonna
come over here like this and i'm gonna
um select this option over here okay
look at that
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
directly add i'm gonna directly add
auto layout look at this okay i'm gonna
right click over here and then add auto
layout or what you can do is you can you
can click shift plus a like this look
shift and a
now look auto layout is added to our
button okay so in order to see that what
we have to do is we're gonna click this
over here and then you see this fill
over here i'm gonna click this over here
like this and i'm gonna change the fill
color to black okay zero zero zero zero
like this and look at that it got
converted to
very dark black okay now i'm gonna come
over here um and then i'm gonna select
control on my keyboard and then right
click i mean left click over here and
then i'm gonna select the text okay the
text is selected or what you can do is
you can come over here on this frame
okay this frame gets highlighted in blue
and then look at this frame
i mean this auto layout frame okay and
inside this frame we have the button
okay you can click this over here or you
can directly uh control and then left
click over here then it's gonna select
the text okay and then you see this
color over here i'm gonna change it to
white okay ffff six times f like this
look
it's gonna bring me back my buttons okay
now let's say that i want to add some
padding to the left and to the right
side of my button so how do i do this
and before doing that what you have to
normally do is we have to select this
over here and then you have to select
this which means that you want the text
to be at the very center of your button
otherwise what happens is if you want to
resize your button let's say that i want
to resize and button look at that the
text is
aligned to the very left it is not
moving okay if i resize it like this
look it is not moving anywhere okay
control that control that now if i set
it to to the very center like this if i
resize my button anywhere anyhow
wherever i wish like that look at that
it this text will stay at the very
center over here like that look at that
i can move it anywhere i want okay ctrl
z now let's say that i want to
individually add some padding okay i'm
going to select over here and then let's
say i want to select padding of um
30 pixels on the left and the right okay
30 over here tap i mean enter 30 over
here hit enter like that look at that we
have 10 pixels of padding
the top bottom and 30 pixels of padding
on the left and right
also i'm going to show you how you can
utilize these two buttons over here to
make responsive layouts for your desktop
tablet mobile web designs more quickly
and efficiently
so keep watching i hope you understood
how to align your content and make
buttons using the auto layout feature
now i'm going to show you this feature
that is left to discuss this feature
over here okay so this is the vertical
direction and this is the horizontal
direction okay i'm gonna remove this
real quick and look at this over here do
you see this layout over here do you see
these cards over here how is this
stacked this is stacked on a horizontal
line and if you see the mobile version
the mobile design look at this
it is stacked vertically like this so
how do we do this very quickly easily
and efficiently okay so i'm gonna come
to this desktop version over here and
then i'm gonna copy this one to the
right side okay or perhaps let's say i
want to copy this over here okay like
that um
there we go i'm gonna extend this like
this okay and then i'm gonna click
one time over here okay and then out
press the alt button on your keyboard
okay like this and then drag it over
here like this look at that okay so
auto layout is also enabled on this one
okay if you see the right
panel over here you see this auto layer
you see this auto layout is enabled okay
do you see this
horizontal direction it is enabled which
means that our cards will act like this
okay it's gonna act on the horizontal
line it's gonna lay out on the
horizontal line but let's say that we
want it to be
on the vertical line which means that we
want to make it for the mobile version
okay what we're gonna do is we're gonna
click it over here like this
look at that boom we made the layout of
our cards for the mobile version look at
that how quickly i made it so the mobile
has small screen okay so i have to
resize it like this let's say that um
i'm gonna come over here and then i'm
gonna hit the k or what you can do is
you can come over here and then select
the scale version over here okay i'm
gonna hit k over here like this and then
click this and then i'm gonna resize it
like this look at that
it got resized if you want to resize
even further according to your uh screen
which is normally small like this look
at that
you can
you can adjust the width and height
accordingly to your needs okay like this
using the scale
in using the scale too
now look at the side by side comparison
how easily and quickly i made layout for
my mobile version from the desktop
version this is the desktop version over
here
and this is the mobile version over here
by the way do you see the content inside
this card this chemistry this button
over here this image over here all of
them are using the auto layout and i
have used aura layout to align the
content at the very center if i drag see
if i select one card like this look at
that okay i have selected this card over
here so look at this content over here
okay if i come to this oral layout look
all the content has 19 pixels of padding
i mean gaps in between and then if i
select this one over here then you can
see that the content is aligned to the
very center like this look at that i
really hope that you understood the auto
layout feature
the next feature that i want to talk
about is the layout grid so you can
select any frame you want across all
these pages either either the desktop
tablet mobile or anything you're gonna
find these frames okay i'm gonna send it
the first one as an example okay and
then you're gonna find this over here
the layout grid so where is this used if
you want to plan your content
i mean if you want to make your web
design responsive for the desktop tablet
mobile etc you need to plan your content
right so using this you can plan your
content let me show you a demo okay so
i'm gonna uh you see the i button over
here i'm gonna click this
this is
used to hide that layout okay like this
look at that okay and this minus sign is
used to delete that layout and this plus
sign is used to add the layout i mean
the layout grid okay
so look at this what is written over
here five columns auto okay so if you
count over here one two three four five
we have five i mean five great columns
okay
so if you click over here like this now
look what is this it is written count
okay you can increase the number of
columns over here you can also select
the color and then you can set the
opacity over here like this as well so
i'm going to click over here like this
and then look at this we have this
option okay columns we can also change
it to grids like this and you can see
this little dots over here like a graph
paper okay you see this
thin lines like this okay
this pattern okay so this is the grid
all right so if you want to change it uh
to let's say columns sorry rows you can
also do it like this look at that it
changed from columns to rows like this
now let's change it back to columns okay
like this i'm going to click over here
and then columns like this now look how
many columns do we have one two three
four five right so look at this over
here we have five columns over here and
look at this margin over here 50 pixels
of margin so if i zoom in over here so
look at this over here you see this
first column over here the gap between
the first column and the start of our
screen over here is 50 pixels this is
the gap i mean this is the margin over
here and regarding the gutter we see we
have 30 pixels of gutter over here okay
now look at this this is the gutter okay
i mean the space between the columns
okay this is 30 pixels now the best
example that i can give you at the
moment um is this one wait a minute uh
this layout over here you see this one
over here offered courses this has three
cards how many cards three cards which
means that we can stack them on three
columns okay let me show you okay i'm
gonna select this and look at this over
here okay i'm gonna
and now i'm gonna click this eye button
over here to show you how the layout
grid is working okay so look at this how
many layouts i mean how many columns do
we have we have three columns and three
cards okay so how many how much gap did
i put between the uh i mean how much
margin did i put okay so i can see it
over here like this okay look at this we
have three columns so it's gonna be
highlighted three over here and the
color is this one red and this is used
to change the transparency okay so if i
increase the size like this look at that
it gets much red okay i'm gonna change
it to uh 10 percent so that it it is
visible
i mean both the layout grid and content
becomes visible okay 10 percent is a
sweet spot and we have margin of 77
pixels okay on the left and the right
and gutter we have 32 pixels a couple of
seconds ago i told you that this layout
grid is used to plan your content when
you are making responsive websites i
mean web designs okay let me show you a
demo okay this is the best example that
i can give you right now so i'm gonna
click this over here and look at this
over here how many columns do we have we
have three columns over here with 77
pixels of margin on the left and the
right and then we have 32 pixels of
gutter okay so this is uh you see this
gap over here
okay white colored space between the red
and our
start of our screen over here this is 77
pixels of margin okay and this gutter
over here you see this white color over
here this is 32 pixels this is the
gutter okay
so
this is the desktop layout okay how many
columns do we have we have three columns
and three columns are stacking three
cards in case of the mobile layout look
at this okay i'm gonna click over here
this mobile on the page section and look
at this how many columns do we have we
have just one single column and this
single column is stacking how many cards
three cards because we have less space
less space on the mobile version okay so
i'm gonna click on this and then i'm
gonna inspect that layout grid okay
so i'm gonna click over here now look
how many columns do we have we have just
one single column and how many margins
do we have 20 pixels of margin now if i
zoom in look at this this space over
here is 20 pixels of margin okay and
this is the mobile layout if we want to
add layout grid on your frame what you
have to do is you're gonna select f okay
on your keyboard like this and then
you're gonna uh drag it like this look
at this we have a frame okay if you want
to add that layout grid you're gonna
select this like this and look at this
over here you see this layout grid over
here you're going to click this over
here like this the plus sign okay then
it's going to add this
pattern over here if you want to change
it then you're going to click this over
here and then you're going to change it
to columns or rows over here according
to your names okay
i hope you understood how to use the
layout great
all right now i'm going to discuss about
the constraints property okay in order
to discuss about the constraints
property you're going to come to this
section i mean this page over here
responsive test
okay so you have noticed this before
okay if you click any element
like this then you're going to find this
constraints property over here i'm going
to discuss about this one okay this is
used to test whether your design is
responsive or not
so i use
the constraints property along with a
plugin
named breakpoints okay so this is the
plugin over here i have actually
included this section for you to test so
you're gonna come over here okay so do
you see these guys over here i'm going
to zoom in a little bit okay i'm going
to come over here you see this these are
our break points 414 pixel is the
breakpoint for the mobile version okay
76 768 pixels is the breakpoint for the
tablet version this is the breakpoint
for the laptop version and this one is
the desktop version okay now look what
happens if i resize it so i'm gonna
click this over here okay look very
carefully look at this the constraint
property is working
when i resize the window like this look
at this our content is at the very
center over here don't worry we're gonna
recreate the results okay just look what
happens
so
when i come to the tablet breakpoint now
look what happens now if i now if i
cross the tablet break right now look
what happens okay here is the tablet
breakpoint so i'm going to cross the
tablet breakpoint okay like this look at
that look our design changed because the
plugin named breakpoints and if i resize
it like this now look what happens we
have some gaps over here okay and the
content is actually at the very center
over here so if i resize it even further
look what happens the font size changes
and the content
increases in size like that look at that
let me actually resize it again okay now
look what happens look at that
small
large this is the laptop this is the
tablet version this is the laptop
version
tablet version
mobile version over here mobile tablet
laptop
the constraint properties used over here
okay i'm going to delete this over here
real quick okay so i'm going to come
over here okay um
wait a minute
now look at this this is the design for
the
laptop version this is the tablet
version over here and this one is the
mobile version over here okay so i'm
gonna just focus on the mobile version
over here like this wait a minute there
we go okay so i'm gonna
bring my options over here and then what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna select all my
elements together okay like this and
then i'm gonna group it together like
this ctrl g now if you select
this one over here and if you notice
over here now you see this
this blue color is highlighted and this
one over here as well this is the top
and this one is the left okay which
means that if you resize the window like
this uh wait a minute
like this then what will happen is your
content will be focused i mean your
content will be locked on the left top
like this look at that but let's say
that you want it to be on the bottom
right so how will you do this
ctrl z okay i'm gonna select this i mean
the entire content section and i'm gonna
select this one okay bottom
right now look what happens if i resize
the window okay now look what happens
it's gonna stay focused i mean it's
gonna stay fixed on the bottom right
look at that
okay now i'm gonna select this one and
i'm gonna drag it down like this look at
that
our content is getting fixed on the
bottom right now let's say that i want
it to be on the bottom left what will i
do i'm gonna do the same thing okay i'm
gonna come to that constraints property
um wait a minute this one okay then i'm
gonna select a bottom left okay i'm
gonna just click this over here or what
i can do i can just
click this over here and
select the left option like this okay
and now look what happens if i resize
the window i'm gonna drag this over here
now look it's gonna stay focused on the
bottom
left
like that so in the case of testing my
responsiveness of my web designs what i
do is i'm gonna
select all my content and then i'm gonna
center both horizontal and vertically
like this okay now look what happens if
i resize the window like this look at
that okay it stays
at the exact center like this okay i do
it for all my contents wait a minute let
me actually
resize it and i'm gonna select all this
content over here like this ctrl g
i have grouped them together i'm gonna
select this and i'm gonna
enable this option okay center center
same thing for the tablet version as
well like this okay control g
and then center center like this now
there is a plugin named breakpoints okay
i'm gonna right click over here and then
select this plugins okay you don't have
to do anything just look what i do okay
and if you want to test it out i'm going
to include this section over here you're
going to come to this section and then
test it on your own how the system works
okay so i'm going to select this plugins
option over here and then i'm going to
and then i'm going to select this
breakpoints
like this
and then it's gonna give me this little
window over here okay i'm gonna select
new adaptive layout like this and then
i'm gonna define my breakpoints over
here and i'm gonna keep it over here as
well
and uh let me actually
all right then i'm gonna select this one
and then i'm gonna write over here
four one four which is the mobile
display breakpoint
okay and then i'm gonna write over here
768 which is the tablet screen and then
i'm gonna click this plus sign over here
okay and then i'm gonna write over here
one zero two four pixels laptop version
and then plus sign over here again over
here one four four zero pixels one four
four zero pixels which is the desktop
version okay now look at this plus sign
over here i'm gonna click this and i'm
gonna select this mobile layout
like this plus sign over here i'm gonna
select this
tablet version okay i'm gonna select
this over here and i'm gonna select this
laptop as well okay
now this is the result we got so far
okay now look this content is at the
very center if i resize it wait a minute
let me actually select this and then
look at this what happens look what
happens okay
oh i actually need to increase the width
over here as well like this look at that
i mean height i need to increase the
height like this now look what happens
if i resize the window okay like this
look at that
so this is the mobile version okay
this is the tablet
version and this one is the laptop
version
the constraints tool and the breakpoint
tool both of them are very handy if you
want to test out your responsiveness
of your web design so i'm going to keep
it as it is so that you can come and
practice over here okay
all right now i'm going to talk about
the tool called components okay so look
at this over here this footer over here
this is actually a component okay we are
gonna
you and me together we're gonna change
this social media icons with this one
over here
i'm gonna come to this assets over here
and look at this social media icons over
here okay we're gonna replace this
so we're gonna replace this one with
these ones over here okay but before
that let's actually test what does our
components do okay so i'm gonna come um
to the left side over here and i'm gonna
draw a frame f and then like this look
at that now let's say that i'm gonna
write some dummy text over here okay
like this a b c d okay ctrl a and i'm
gonna change the size to let's say 100
pixels okay like this look at that okay
i'm gonna change the
font weight to regular okay now look
what happens if i copy this to let's say
three times okay
this is the second time this is the
third time over here okay i'm gonna zoom
in a little bit like this
now look what happens let's say that um
one of many benefits of
the components function is that it helps
you to stop repeating the same design
again and again there's a there is a day
and night difference between copying and
pasting the same thing and using the
components okay let's say that i have
copied and pasted three times over here
okay one two three let's say that um i
want to remove the c okay i don't need
the c okay so what i so what i have to
do is i'm gonna select this over here
and i'm gonna remove the
c over here like this okay same thing i
have to repeat how many times three
times one time two time over here like
this
okay and three time over here like this
look at that
but if i use a component that
wait a minute let me actually remove
this from here and i'm gonna write abcd
over here okay if i write oh sorry
now if i make it a component
how to make a component okay i'm going
to click this button over here create
component or what i can do is i can
right click over here and create
component like this now look this is a
component over here you can see you can
tell it but you can tell it by looking
at this icon over here or
you can also you can also tell it by
looking this highlight over here a
component is highlighted in purple color
okay
now look what happens if i copy from
this component okay alt and then
click over here and then drag like this
okay
now look at this
over here look at my layers over here
this is a diamond shape which means that
this is an instance
of the parent component this is the
parent this is an instance okay i'm
gonna do it the same like this again
let's say i want to do it more three
times okay like this look at that
and let's say that i have to change it i
mean i have to remove the c what will i
do i have to remove it
six times i have to do the same thing
six times but if i use a component like
this one now look what happens if i
remove the c from the parent component
like this look at that i remove this c
the c is removed in all my six designs
over here look at that by just changing
this one over here and nothing else
everything is changed this is the main
selling point of the components okay so
i'm going to delete this from here and
look at this design over here i mean
look at my footer over here
this social media icons is it is blue in
color it doesn't go with our theme if i
come to our color palette over here look
at this this is my color palette over
here okay you can check the
hex value over here as well look at this
hex value and this hex value as well
all right now this doesn't go with our
color over here this is blue color light
blue color so i'm gonna change it to
black and white okay this one over here
this if you come to this assets over
here this one okay now what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna click this frame over here
and then hit alt on my keyboard like
this and then i'm gonna drag it like
this okay it's gonna get copy and then
i'm gonna right click and then i'm gonna
select this option over here move page
to desktop okay i'm gonna come to text
over here um wait a minute there we go
we have our design over here you
actually need to you actually need to
zoom out a little bit so that you can
see where
the frame is okay like this i got my
frame over here
all right now now i'm gonna select this
one this
now i'm gonna select this twitter option
over here by double clicking over here
and then double clicking again like this
now i can see the exact
width and height of my twitter over here
i mean twitter icon over here it is
48.81 pixels so i'm going to copy this
from here like this ctrl c
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
resize my all of my
social media icons okay like this i'm
gonna select this over here and then i'm
gonna hit k on my keyboard okay like
this i can resize it like this look at
that
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna lock
it over here like this this is the
constraints property
and then ctrl v if i paste it over here
then it then this value will
automatically get applied on my height
over here as well okay so i'm gonna
select enter like this now look at that
it gave me accurate calculations so i'm
gonna drag it over here wait a minute
over here like this
by the way this photo over here is the
main parent component okay which means
that if we change anything over here
then all the children
then all the children components i mean
all the instances will get changed as
well look at this i place the social
media icon the facebook black and white
over here
on the parent component and it got
applied over here on the children
component same thing goes for all the
children components as well look at that
we have this facebook icon over here now
i'm going to delete this one over here
okay the blue colored one so what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna come over here and
then i'm gonna double click over here
and then i'm gonna delete like this so
it got removed and the same thing got
removed from all the parent i mean
children components as well look at that
wouldn't have the social media icons
over here
same thing for all the footer instances
okay so i'm gonna come back over here
and i'm gonna resize them also in a
similar manner i'm gonna hit k and then
resize it like this look at that
and then i'm gonna hit this constraints
property and then i'm gonna paste the
value that i have copied okay control v
enter look at that
so i'm gonna select it
together and i'm gonna drag it
on here
like this okay
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
arrange the serial like this
and then i'm gonna hit shift plus a
after dragging
after selecting all this okay like this
shift a
and then i can adjust the gap over here
like this let's say i want gap of 10
pixels okay
i'll i change my mind i'm going to
select it 20 like this there we go i can
also change the stroke as well okay if i
select ctrl on my keyboard and if i
select this stroke over here like this
then i just gonna select me this look at
this i'm gonna change it to two
okay and i'm gonna do the same thing
over here hit ctrl on your keyboard and
then hit ctrl on your keyboard and then
select this circle over here and then
change it to two from 3.5 to like this
look at that it looks beautiful
double click over here and then
follow the orange colored guides okay
look our content is look our social
media icons are aligned
to the left according to those text over
there okay now if i inspect all of my uh
let me actually delete this from here
now in now if i inspect all of my
children instances look at this the same
thing got applied over here because that
is
because we change the parent component
all the children's all the children
instances are bound to change
look at that i really hope that you
understood how to use this useful tool
named components
congratulations guys we're done
discussing all the essential tools of
figma now we're gonna start making our
web design for the desktop version let's
get started but the first question is
how will we practice all right then
we're going to practice like this over
here we're going to draw our frames okay
like this and then we're going to copy
this design on our practice case over
here
as a beginner this is completely fine to
copy others works and designs because
this is a part of the learning process
so i'm going to click this from here
like this and then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to move this to the right
side okay and then i'm going to draw a
frame over here like this follow along
with me i'm going to hold my shift and
then i'm going to select the names like
this okay i mean names of the frame like
this all right and then i'm gonna select
the footers and then i'm gonna drag it
over here like this there we go now what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna zoom in over
here okay by the way this is my color
palette over here i'm gonna keep it over
here um there we go and then i'm gonna
make a frame over here okay so i'm gonna
um select my f which is frame tool okay
f and then i'm gonna select this over
here okay
desktop
and then this one desktop which has
a dimension of 440 pixels in width like
this look at that okay i'm gonna keep it
over here like this the first thing that
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna make grid
layers okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna select this element over here
okay and then i'm gonna select this
little icon over here okay so that i can
see the grid is over here and then i'm
gonna select this so that i can better
see
what is the margin and what is the
gutter over here okay we can see 50 we
can see 50 pixels of margin over here
but let's say that in certain scenarios
you cannot actually see how much is the
margin over here so what will you do in
this case in this case is what you can
do is uh let me actually show you a
trick over here so i'm going to come
over here okay you see my text over here
and this gap over here i'm gonna draw a
rectangle over here let me actually show
you okay i'm gonna hit r
and then i'm gonna draw a little
rectangle over here and i'm gonna keep
it over here like this and it's gonna
snap inside this let me actually zoom in
a little bit so that you can better see
how this is working all right so look at
this rectangle over here and then i'm
gonna stretch it to this till this side
over here okay like this wait a minute
like this look at that this rectangle is
filling that gap over here now if i
select this over here and if i inspect
this rectangle you can see that this
rectangle is 50 pixels in width which
means that here is 50 pixels of gap so
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
remove this rectangle from here all
right then i'm going to come to my main
design over here i'm in the practice
case and then i'm going to give this one
over here auto a layout grid okay like
this and then i'm gonna change it to
columns like this okay and then i'm
gonna give here how many pixels of
margin 50 because we found out
so the rectangle that it is 50 pixels of
margin okay like that and let's actually
see what we have specified in the grid
like this okay
and 30 pixels of girder okay
there we go like that um 30 pixels over
here if you hold shift and up if you
hold shift and then press the up arrow
button then it's gonna change
10 scale at a time like this look it is
20 30 40 50 60 70 80 while i'm holding
the shift but if you release the shift
and if you use the arrow sign
i mean up arrow sign then what will
happen is it's gonna change one pixel
one pixel like that it is 80 pixels okay
81 82 83 84 85
86 is gonna take a lot of time so i'm
gonna use the shift okay i'm gonna jump
to 36 and then i'm going to write 30
over here like this there we go
looks quite perfect now now we're going
to make this nav bar over here okay in
order to inspect this element what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
select control on my keyboard okay and
then i'm gonna click over here like this
now you can see all the properties over
here do you see this the color the font
family
the font weight font size etcetera okay
so look at this it is 90 pixels so i'm
going to copy this one here like this
ctrl c and i'm going to come over here
and then and then hit t on your keyboard
like this t and then click over here
okay and write edu oh sorry
edu
dot io
and the phone family is four pins which
is
correct over here change it to semi bold
over here like this and then select 90
over here like this
90 okay okay i'm gonna keep it over here
like this okay do you see this orange
color guides it's gonna snap like this
okay so you don't have to do anything
manually
the next thing that we have is home
teachers contact us sign in options by
the way you have this
desktop typography guide over here which
you can follow okay so this logo is 90
pixels over here the nav items
each of these nav items
are 47 pixels in
size okay so i'm going to come over here
i'm going to hit t on my keyboard like
this t
click and i'm gonna write home over here
okay
same thing
i'm gonna copy it four times like this
one
two three and then four okay i'm gonna
write over here teachers
and i'm to write over here contact us
and over here signing
we also need to change the font way we
also need to change the font wait in
order to inspect the font weight i'm
going to come over here on the original
design
and then i'm gonna click control on my
keyboard click like this look at this we
have regular and 47 pixels also the font
size we have regular font weight 47
pixels font size and look at this the
font family is robot okay so i'm gonna
come over here
like this and i'm gonna select all of
them together how will i do this look at
that i'm gonna drag all of them together
like this select all of them together
like this and i'm gonna write over here
47 okay
enter and then i'm going to write
regular over here like this look at that
and then i'm going to write over here
roboto because the font is removed over
there on the original design robot there
we go now the next thing that i'm going
to do is i'm going to select all of them
together like this and then shift a or
what i can do is i'm gonna write i'm
gonna right click over here and then add
auto layout or you can also do it by
using the shortcut shift plus a
i'm gonna do it over here like this all
right now i'm going to click this over
here because it should be on the
horizontal line like this look at that
there we go and then i'm going to click
this over here and i'm going to select
this so that it always i mean all the
text should remain at the center over
here both horizontal and vertically
inside this frame like this look at that
and now the next thing that i'm going to
do is i'm going to snap it to this side
over here of my great lines okay like
that look at that
there we go it snaps like this
all right now
now if i look at the original design
over here okay if i select this over
here by double clicking over here like
this then you can see that we have 50
pixels of gap which means that it should
be 50 pixels of gap as well
between the between the nav items so i'm
going to click this over here like this
and it is set to 93 so i'm going to
change it to 50 pixels
there we go i'm going to set i'm going
to snap it on the grid lines over here
like this again and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to select both the logo and
the nav items like this
oh by the way you should change the home
text to
medium okay you're gonna click this over
here and then from regular to medium
like this okay because on the original
design over here it is set to medium as
well because this is the current design
all right then so i'm going to click
both of them together like this and then
shift plus a
now look at that my nav items are
shifted at the top in order to bring it
at the very middle at the very center
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
click this over here okay and then
select this over here now look it looks
exactly carbon copy of the original
document
and original design now look at this
over here on the original design we have
this rectangle over here okay i mean
underline over here how do you create
this okay follow along with me okay so
i'm gonna click this over here and then
i'm gonna lock it i'm gonna lock my
content like this okay i'm gonna zoom in
over here like this i'm gonna select the
rectangle tool by pressing the r button
on my keyboard r and then i'm gonna
select i mean i'm gonna make a rectangle
over here like this i'm gonna resize it
like this so that i can see the orange
guides over here okay
orange guides are snapping like this
look at that
i'm gonna change it like this uh seven
seven pixels in height
and 126 pixels in width okay now i'm
going to change the
corner radius like this i'm going to
write 10 over here okay there we go and
in order to change the color what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna select this okay
while selecting that look at this color
palette over here okay i'm gonna select
this color from here and then this i
button over here okay like that and then
i'm gonna select this one look at that
i have successfully changed the color
and also made this underline on my nav
items there we go it looks quite the
same as this one now the next thing that
we need is the image this asset over
here okay so
so so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
come to this assets page over here okay
and then look at this we have the asset
over here so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna select this and then press the alt
keyboard press the alt key on my
keyboard like this and then i'm gonna
drag it like hit
i'm gonna drag it like this over here
and i'm gonna right click over here and
then
move to page
desktop like this then it's gonna send
me to the desktop page over here but you
actually need to search where the asset
has moved okay by
zooming out like this and there we go we
have our asset over here like this okay
now look at this we have some
unnecessary gap around our illustration
just like a
tattoo okay so i'm gonna select this
over here now look at all of these files
over here do you see this on welcome
number two this is a frame okay so look
at this
we have so many vectors over here i'm
gonna select the very last one like this
this one okay i'm gonna select the very
last one over here and then what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna literally delete
this from here kill it now look at that
that white space went away i'm gonna
select this text over here okay i mean
i'm gonna select the whole frame like
this now look we still have some gap
around our illustration now what you're
gonna do is you're gonna select this
over here you see this okay select this
and then select group over here now look
all the white space went away like that
so i'm gonna bring it over here like
this
now the next thing that we're gonna do
is we're gonna copy the width and height
of this image okay by double clicking
over here now do you see this
so the first thing that we can do is we
can either copy both of them together
and then paste them
on this
illustration one by one but if you want
to save some a little bit of time what
you can do is you can just select this
one and then copy the only the width
okay control c and then you select this
one and then you click this constraints
proportion okay like this and then paste
it over here like this now what it will
do is it's gonna
scale our illustration
proportionately it's gonna it's gonna
follow the proportional measurement
and also it's gonna change our height as
well according to the proportional
measurements okay so i'm gonna
click enter like this there we go now
look it looks as similar as this one you
see this
i'm keeping i'm keeping both of them on
top of another
look it looks quite the same okay so i'm
gonna bring it over here and then i'm
gonna take the help of this orange
colored guide and snap my image over
here on my grids like that look at that
all right now regarding the text how do
we write the text okay so i'm going to
double click over here and double click
over here again like this now it's going
to copy the text okay ctrl c you don't
have to write anything okay just copy
the text
okay so i'm going to come over here and
then t
click over here okay control v
so i have copied the text over here and
along with that it changed
those this is over here as well
all right so i'm going to keep it over
here like this
and i'm going to come back over here
like this double click over here and if
you want to copy something quickly what
you're going to do is you're going to
double click over here okay
and then you're going to hit alt on your
keyboard out and then drag it over here
like this look at that
it got copied very quickly like this now
regarding the button how to create a
button i'm gonna use the auto layout
okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
come over here and then firstly
i'm gonna hit the t okay
click and i'm gonna write login okay
sorry
log in now let's see the properties of
this text over here okay control click
like this 45 pixels bold robot okay
so i'm going to write robot over here
roberto
and bold over here
45 here as well enter now look what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna click this over here
and then right click
add auto layout like this look at that
okay now we have a
invisible background so i'm gonna click
it over here and do you see the fill
over here i'm gonna click this fill
i'm gonna select this over here okay and
do you see my color palette over here
this is actually not complete black it
is actually it has a color okay do you
see this color over here it is this
color so i'm gonna select this again and
the fill i'm gonna um select this one
and this i button over here and then i'm
gonna click over here like this look at
that it got very dark so i'm gonna
double click over here on the text or
ctrl click like this
okay so and then this is set to black
i'm gonna select this and fff six times
or three times you can also write it
three times fff enter look at that we
have white color text inside our black
colored button so i'm gonna click this
over here and i'm gonna set some border
radius okay
i mean corner radius let's set it to
eight pixels okay let's actually see the
original one it is actually uh 18 pixels
okay and width is this one so i'm going
to copy the width from here ctrl c and
the height is 105 pixels okay and i'm
going to paste it over here look at that
you cannot actually change it over here
but in this case is
what you can do is you can you're going
to come over here and just
drag it over here like this a little bit
a little bit not too much and you can
see this it got unlocked and the height
is blocked in order to unlock that
height you're gonna click over here like
this and you're gonna drag it like this
look at that the height and width both
of them got unlocked okay so i'm gonna
paste the width over here control v
enter
okay don't worry we're gonna change the
properties okay and the height should be
um wait a minute it should be i guess 72
105 okay i'm gonna select this and one
zero five enter now look we need the
text to be at the very center do you
remember this property over here this
little icon i'm going to select this and
i'm going to click this over here so
that it gets
centered at the very middle like this
look at that both horizontally
vertically
look at that we got our solution over
here
all right so i'm going to keep the
button over here and i'm going to
and i'm going to replicate another
button how do i do this
alt on your keyboard and drag it like
this look at that and i'm going to write
over here what come on tell me sign up
this one okay
wait a minute sign
up
okay so always always turn this one on
so that
extra white spaces gets reduced
and the button stays i mean the button
text remains at the very center okay so
i'm going to click it over here again so
that
uh this is enable okay order width is
enabled so what this does is it removes
all the extra white spaces so that your
button looks proportional aesthetic
so now look at this even if we have a
buttons like this
what we're gonna do is we're gonna use
our layout okay so i'm gonna select both
of them together and shift plus a like
this look at that okay and then i'm
going to click this over here and then
center over here like this so that it
always remains at the center
and look at this we also need to add
some drop shadow to our buttons how do
we do this i'm going to click it over
here like this and look at this fx over
here i'm going to click it over here
like this okay
now let's look at our original document
what is the
property of our effect the drop shadow
effect okay so i'm going to select this
button over here like this wait a minute
like this and then i'm going to select
this drop shadow over here so it is set
to 10 on the x y
is 10 and the blur is 4 over here okay
so i'm going to come to this practice
over here and then i'm going to select
the button i'm going to select this drop
shadow i'm going to set it over here 10
like this the blur is 4 that's fine and
for the y it should be 10 like this
there we go now in order to transfer
this blur radius to this button over
here instead of doing it again instead
of repeating the same thing what you're
going to do is you're going to click
over here double click over here and
then look at this
i'm gonna double click over here and
then i'm gonna right click over here and
then copy
slash paste okay i'm gonna copy the
properties and i'm gonna double click
over here and right click and then i'm
gonna paste the properties over here
like this look at that i have
successfully transferred the box shadow
of the first button to the second button
over here like that look at that this is
how the copy paste properties works okay
so far so good now let's look at the gap
between the buttons on the original
document okay so i'm gonna come over
here now instead of looking at the oral
layout
what you can do is you can just select
this first second button over here and
then alt you hit alt and wherever you
place the mouse it's gonna show that
distance between that button and the
element like this look at that i'm going
to keep my mouse on the first button
over here
let me show this to you again okay so
i'm going to double click over here
and double click again or
just hit control on your keyboard and
then right click
left click sorry like this
and you're gonna hit alt on your
keyboard okay and you're gonna place
your mouse
on the first button over here now look
at this let me actually zoom in okay
look at this we have 53 pixels of gap
between the first and the second button
so i'm gonna come over here as you
remember that we have enabled all layout
on our buttons over here so i'm gonna
click this over here and then i'm gonna
come over here and write 53 pixels of
gap okay five three enter like that look
at that
now regarding the gap between our text
over here and the text over here i mean
the first text and the second text what
you're gonna do is you're gonna do the
same thing okay i'm gonna come over here
like this
i'm gonna control click like this and
then i'm gonna hit alt on my keyboard
alt and then i'm gonna put my mouse on
the second text look at that we have 41
pixels i can see 41 pixels of cap so i'm
going to come over here and instead of
doing manually
just
select both of them together like this
and shift plus a and then you click this
option
and then you're gonna do it like this
okay you're gonna keep it at the middle
middle left like that look at that okay
so how much was the gap again 41 right
so i'm gonna come over here and do you
see this option after clicking this 41
pixel like that 41 enter there we go now
let's look at the difference i mean the
distance between the buttons and the
text okay i'm going to select this
button over here and then same process
okay alt on your keyboard and then
select that text over here like this
look at that 41 pixels as well so i'm
going to come over here
and i'm going to select this and the
button like this look at that and then
shift plus a
now i'm gonna write 41 over here enter
there we go
look at that we have successfully copied
the design
from the main
design to our practice case over here
now we actually need to align our
content according to these gaps and
various properties right so i'm gonna
click
on here okay
this block over here and then i'm gonna
click alt on my keyboard same process
right so i'm gonna keep a mouse at the
bottom so that i can see the gap
between my screen and the content look
at that it is 109 pixels over here you
see this 109 pixels
so i'm going to come back over here
click this and then alt
i'm gonna hit alt on my keyboard and
then i'm gonna put my mouse over here
like this look at that this is two
hundred thousand pixels of gap between
this corner i mean this
window and this
content over here okay so what was the
original one it was 109 so what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna drag it at the
bottom like this okay and then i'm gonna
test it again okay i'm gonna click this
over here and alt
and then i'm gonna put my mouse over
here
look it is 124 which means that i have
to go a little bit
below
like that okay let's test again
alt over here 104 so i'm going to click
this
and then 105
press the up arrow on my keyboard okay
104 it is currently 104 okay 105 106 7 8
9 like that and i'm gonna select this
over here and alt
on my keyboard
put my mouse over here look at this this
is perfect 109 pixels over here
regarding our image over here let's fix
that as well so i'm gonna come over here
and i'm gonna select this image over
here by double clicking over here and
i'm gonna press alt on my keyboard alt
and then i'm gonna put my mouse over
here 167 pixels over here okay so i'm
gonna come over here back over here and
then drag it at the bottom okay and then
i'm gonna select alt look at that 140
pixels okay so i'm gonna click this over
here shift and up arrow shift
up so it's gonna move 10 pixels okay so
it's currently 150 160 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 i
have pressed 7 times my up arrow now
look at that i'm going to click this
over here and alt
i'm going to put my mouse over here like
that look at that 167 pixels of gap
between our image i mean illustration
and the bottom screen
now look at this original design over
here do you see this little doodles over
here do you see these little flakes over
here how to recreate them let me show
you okay so i'm going to zoom out and
i'm going to come to this assets page
over here okay so now look now look i
have actually included this flakes
illustration over here okay so i'm gonna
click this and i'm gonna copy this like
this alt drag like this okay right click
move page to desktop okay so i'm going
to come to desktop over here zoom out
and look at
and look where the file is okay the file
is over here i mean the frame is over
here okay so i'm going to click it over
here like this and i'm going to bring it
back
over here like this wait a minute
there we go now look i'm going to zoom
in into the main file okay
like this now look at that we have this
triangle over here circle over here and
then this wave pattern over here how to
recreate that so i'm gonna come to this
a flakes image over here and first of
all what was it triangle okay so i'm
gonna copy a triangle from here look at
that we have a triangle over here so i'm
gonna
hit control on my keyboard and then
click over here like this look at that i
have selected this okay so i'm gonna
now i'm gonna hit the alt keyboard to
copy okay alt and then i'm gonna drag it
from here like that look at that do you
see this you see what is on my hand over
here i have copied it so i'm gonna paste
it over here directly on my
practice image over here okay like this
i'm gonna release my mouse and then i'm
gonna release the alt key there we go
now the next thing is i have this uh
circle over here okay now in order to
select the circle look at the circle
over here i'm gonna select this uh ctrl
click and then alt drag like this okay
now i'm gonna come over here and i'm
gonna select this over here and then i'm
gonna um
increase the size a little bit how to do
that i'm gonna hit k on my keyboard and
then i'm gonna drag it like this a
little bit and then it's gonna
become a little bit bigger okay now what
is it what do we have we have this wave
pattern over here okay so i'm gonna come
over here
and i'm gonna select this wave over here
now it's a bit now look at this this is
a little bit tricky okay so this wave is
actually
multiple icons together okay if i
control and click over here now look at
this this whole this whole wave doesn't
get selected okay just a single part
gets selected so in this case what
should you do you're gonna select you're
gonna hit ctrl and shift both of them
together okay like this
ctrl shift and then click like this
click click click click okay and then
you're gonna do what you're gonna do
you're gonna you're gonna
press ctrl g on your keyboard which
means we're gonna make it a group or
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
right click over here and then make it a
group selection like this look at that
now this will behave like a
single element instead of behaving like
a four individual different elements
okay now i'm gonna copy this from here
alt click okay now i'm gonna come back
over here and i'm going to paste it over
here and then i'm going to rotate it a
little bit okay like that
there we go
so it looks quite similar to this one
now i'm going to increase the gap
between them
like this look at that
there we go and in order to change the
color of this triangle and this wave
pattern what you're going to do is
you're going to come over here on the
main design control shift okay click
this one
and then click this one oh sorry you're
gonna click on
you're gonna you're gonna click on here
first okay and then
click this over here then eyedropper
over here and then you're gonna select
this one okay
so far so good you're gonna click this
over here and then select this fill over
here
then this eyedropper over here okay and
then you're gonna select this one there
we go look at that we have colored our
flakes like that okay it looks quite
similar to the original design this is
our practice case and this is our design
over here look at that
now we have a lot of flakes over here
around our image over here and then we
have a little bit of over here so i'm
gonna pause the video and complete all
of these doodles over here in the
meantime you do the same you pause the
video
and you complete you see the original
file over here and then you mimic the
same on your practice case over here
all right so i'm gonna see you after a
couple of minutes
so welcome back i have completed all of
these doodles over here like this look
at that it looks quite the carbon copy
of the original design over here
congratulations we're done creating our
first web design now let's move on to
the next section this one over here okay
we're gonna design this
so i'm gonna come over here and create a
frame f okay and then desktop over here
like this look at that i have created
this frame over here and then i'm gonna
come to this assets over here and then
select this one okay
this painter over here and then copy it
from here like this and right click send
it to
i mean move to page desktop over here
okay i'm gonna come back to desktop over
here and i'm gonna search for the file
where is it there is it we have our
painter over here like that okay i'm
gonna
zoom in a little bit and the process is
same
do you remember the process you need to
remove this white colored background so
select this and look at this highlighted
over here okay so i'm gonna delete this
vector at the very bottom over here
right click left click over here and
then delete like that look at that and
now we're going to select this and then
come over here on the frame select it to
group and it's going to remove all the
unnecessary
white spaces okay so i'm going to keep
it over here like that
now i'm going to come over here and i'm
going to inspect this element what is it
my double
and now i'm going to come over here and
double click over here to inspect the
element with this width over here 657
click it over here ctrl c come back over
here like this click and then click this
over here constrain proportions okay and
then paste it over here like this ctrl c
enter there we go
like that and i'm gonna
keep it at the center like this and keep
it at the center like this or what you
can do is you can just select this
align horizontal centers like this oh
sorry not this one
this one align vertical centers like
this and it's gonna get snapped to the
very center hor uh
vertically okay
there we go and we're getting this text
over here what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
control click over here like this and
then i'm gonna hit alt on my keyboard
drag it like this look at that i i'm
gonna keep it over here like this okay
same thing i'm gonna do the same thing
for this text over here as well control
click
and then hit alt alt drag
like this look at that
the process is same you're gonna click
over here and then alt and then move
your mouse to this first text okay how
many space do you see it is 80 pixels
okay so i'm going to come over here and
shift plus a shift a like this and i'm
going to keep it at the very middle over
here like this i'm going to click this
there we go and it should be how much
gap 80 pixels right it is currently set
to 51 pixels so right a like this okay
enter
there we go and then i'm going to come
back to this button over here so i
already have this button we already
created the button so i'm gonna come
over here and double click on this
button
double click on this button double click
again over here okay
so i'm gonna copy this button by writing
by hitting alt and then drag like this
look at that okay
i'm gonna keep it over here raise it and
i'm gonna change the text to get started
okay like that double click over here
get
started
all right now looks quite good so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to click on
this button over here and then alt on my
keyboard and then i'm going to put my
mouse on this text look at this how much
gap do we have we have 80 pixels of gap
so i'm going to come back over here
and give 80 pixels of gap as well okay
so in order to do it quickly i'm going
to click it over here like this shift
plus a okay and then i'm going to click
over here and i'm going to keep it on
the very middle like this and then i'm
going to write 80 over here it is
actually set to 81 80 enter there we go
we're done
and regarding the flicks and you're
getting this little flakes over here i'm
gonna pause the video and complete it
you do the same you pause the video and
create these flakes over here as i have
showed you how to create these flakes so
then i'm going to see you in a couple of
minutes
so far so good we actually forgot to
include the layout grid so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to click over
here and then
layout create enable by clicking it like
this okay and then i'm going to click
over here and then change it to columns
okay oh sorry not rows columns like this
and i'm going to set the margin to 50
pixels over here like this okay
and then cutter should be 30 like this
all
right now we're going to snap now now
we're going to snap the content to the
very right side over here like this
and then we're going to snap this image
this illustration to the very left side
over here like this okay there we go
looks quite good
we're done with this section over here
now i'm going to show you how you can
make cards now i'm going to show you how
you can make cards over here like this
okay so i'm going to create a frame over
here f okay and then select this option
over here
and then i'm going to keep it side by
side over here all right
now look at this over here so you do
manually
so you do all of this works manually
okay i'm just gonna copy
and paste it over here i'm just gonna
show you how to create these cards okay
so i'm gonna copy from here like this
and alt drag it like this okay
and i'm gonna keep these elements moving
as long as i don't see the orange
colored sky okay like this look at that
you see the orange
do you see this orange colored guides
over here like this look at that i'm
gonna release it right now like this
all right then so i'm gonna
now i'm gonna do the same thing for this
little elements over here like this okay
including the buttons
alt drag like this okay i'm gonna keep
it over here
now select the first frame i mean the
original design okay and see the grids
like this
so i'm going to click over here like
this wait a minute
we have 77 pixels of margin and gutter
32 pixels so i'm going to click over
here and
click the layout grid over here like
this so
i'm going to change it to columns over
here okay so the margin is 77 pixels so
77 enter like this and the gutter was
how much let me actually inspect it
again 32 okay click it again
click this one 32 over here okay wait a
minute 32 there we go
and we should have how many columns
three columns okay click this three
enter all right now
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
click over here and remove this columns
like this and
double click over here on the cards look
at this
width and height look at this one look
at the width and height of our
card number one okay it is 400
in width by
633 in height so i'm going to come back
over here and i'm going to select a
rectangle by clicking r on my keyboard
okay click over here like this which
should be 400 okay enter and what should
be the height let's actually inspect
like this
um 633 okay so click over here like this
right 6 3 3 6 3 3 enter
there we go we have our cards okay i'm
gonna place it over here like this and
what up and now what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna remove the
color you see this color is dark gray
color okay so i'm gonna snap it over
here on my
layout grid okay and then i'm gonna
remove in order to remove the color
you click this minus sign over here like
this and in order to see the
rectangle you click this stroke over
here okay and then select it to three
pixels like this or perhaps even four
root two
enter there we go and now look at this
border radius we also have border radius
around our main design okay so i'm going
to create so i'm going to create a
border radius over here by clicking over
here like this uh wait a minute there we
go and it should be 15 pixels okay
look it looks quite good
and looks
like the original one as well
and i'm gonna
select this and i'm gonna create two
more copies okay alt drag like this do
it again alt and drag like this
there we go
i'm gonna
keep it at the top over here like this
i'm gonna
take it i'm gonna take it off the top as
well and look at this
i'm gonna place it at the
center of our grid like this okay like
this wait a minute
like this there we go
now how to place these images okay come
back to assets okay you see these three
images over here
let's copy them okay by selecting them
one by one by selecting them all by
selecting all of them together okay
shift
click
click on the name click on the name okay
now alt copy like this alt
drag over here like this okay now
right click move to page desktop like
this okay and go to desktop zoom out and
see where is it here is our images okay
click over here click over here click
over here like this
bring it over here
like this
and
do you remember the steps you're gonna
click over here
and you're gonna scroll at the very
bottom over here and remove this vector
from here okay delete click it click on
this click on this frame over here and
then change it to group over here like
this now it's gonna remove all our extra
additional
white spaces okay now drag it over here
like this come over here on the main
design
control i mean
select this one and look at this width
and height 359 control this one
and come over here select this
select this little constraint button
over here like this and paste it over
here like this ctrl v enter there we go
we have a little icon over here we can
place it over here like this and do you
see this
we have a little part over here do you
see this part we don't have this part
over here okay so in order to remove
that we're gonna come over here and
control click like this and hit the
delete keyboard hit the delete key on
your keyboard and it's gonna get
vanished like that look at that there we
go let's copy the names from here
control click alt drag like this do the
same process for the music and pharmacy
as well
like that control click
alt drag over here like this and do the
same process do the same process for
this images over here you pause the
video take a minute and complete the
process okay i'm gonna come back in a
minute
all right now i'm done doing the process
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
center our image and the text at the
very center of our card
how do we do this we're gonna click both
the illustration and the chemistry
like this and i'm gonna shift plus a or
click this oral layout over here like
this okay now look it's gonna get at the
very center and the next thing that
you're gonna do is you're gonna click it
over here like this
and click it over here to keep it keep
it at the center both horizontal and
vertically okay like this look at that
okay and click it over here again and
remove all of this
gap over here okay zero like this enter
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
copy this button from here okay control
control click over here like this and
alt drag
okay place it over here like this
do the same for all the cards as well
like this
now let's look at the gap between our
button and our text okay so i'm gonna
come over here and control click and alt
press the alt button on your keyboard
and put your mouse on this text over
here now look we have 19 pixels of gap
okay so i'm going to come back over here
click this one and click this one by
clicking my shift key by clicking my
shift key on my keyboard like this shift
plus a it should be 19 okay i'm gonna
put 19 over here and in order to put
this button on the very center i'm going
to click this over here and click this
there we go now click both of them
together like this
now you're gonna click and then alt plus
h
which means that we're gonna center both
of them horizontally and vertically
together so alt plus h
alpha plus h
all plus v like that
look at that we have horizontal and
vertically centered both the card and
the content
okay like that and i'm gonna select both
of them together and i can either
group them together in a group or i can
also use the order layout so i'm gonna
just use the group okay ctrl g like that
it became a small group over here
now you duplicate the same process and
fix these cards over here okay i'll
leave this to you
do you see this design over here this is
the same as number one over here and
number two over here okay so you're
gonna do this on your own also i believe
that you can make this footer over here
so i'm not doing this i'm just keeping
this for you now let me show you how i
made these cards over here okay so i'm
gonna come back to my assets over here
and i'm gonna come to uh let's say that
i want to select just the first one okay
i'm gonna select this and alt drag over
here like this okay right click move to
page desktop okay
like this it moved to my desktop let me
zoom out um here is my asset over here
i'm gonna keep it over here oh by the
way what you're gonna do is you're gonna
move this to the right side by clicking
over here shift click like this
okay you're gonna select all of them
together like this and you're gonna move
it like this there we go it got moved
over here like this and i'm gonna come
over here and i'm gonna select my f
on my keyboard okay f and then i'm gonna
create this desktop frame like this look
at that and i'm gonna drag it over here
like this
there we go and regarding this and
regarding the nav bar what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna copy it from here okay and
then i'm gonna paste it over here like
this alt and then drag it over here like
this
there we go
but before that we also need to enable
the layout grid like this ctrl
click this over here and then layout
grid over here and change it to
columns columns over here and then
what is the margin
click over here and enable this over
here like this look at that we have this
column
grid over
column grid over here select this over
here and we have three columns and how
many margins 50 pixels of margin okay 70
pixels of gutter so come back over here
like this
select this over here
right three over here okay
so how much was it 50 and 70 50 pixels
margin 70 pixels gutter come back over
here and write 50 um wait a minute 50
over here
and 70 gutter
there we go
okay now so i'm gonna select the first
image over here okay double click over
here like this double click over here
double click again over here
now keep clicking unless you don't
select the image okay
like this look now i have selected the
image look at that i can see the width
and height over here as well so i'm
going to copy the width over here like
this ctrl c
now i'm going to come back over here
okay i'm going to select my frame over
here you see this white space
how to remove that we're going to click
over here and convert it to a group like
this
now look we don't have any white space
so click on here like this and then
enable this one okay constraints
property and then paste the width over
here like this ctrl v enter
there we go we have our image over here
okay now how do i now how did i do this
circle over here pretty straight forward
okay we're going to select this circle
by
ctrl
click like this now look at this i have
a circle of 198 by 198 pixels okay so
i'm going to click my zero i mean oh on
my key oh on my keyboard like this enter
sorry click now look at this i have this
circle over here click this constraints
properly and write 198 like this 198
enter okay now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna uh keep it over here like
this look at that
in case if the circle is
something like in case if the circle
looks something like this wait a minute
let me actually show you
in case if the circle looks something
like this what you're gonna do is you're
gonna right click on the circle send to
back like that okay and i'm gonna keep
it over here unless i don't see the
orange colored guide okay look at that
it's gonna be it should be at the very
center over here okay uh if you don't
see the guides what you're gonna do is
you're gonna
select both of them together and hit alt
h which means
center horizontally like that now you're
going to select both of them together
and then do you see this option over
here used as a mask i'm going to select
this now look at that i have this option
over here again make a circle okay zero
o on your keyboard click over here and
then use this
198 like this tap ah sorry enter like
this now there we go now what you're
going to do is you're going to remove
the fill from here do you see this it
has a fill
it is um gray in color do you see this
gray color over here on our circle
you're going to remove the circle uh
fill and then you're going to select the
stroke over here and select three over
here like this enter
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
bring it over here like this just do you
see this over here now bring it over
here like this
now if you if you move the circle if you
try to move the circle like this you're
gonna see orange colored guide which
will snap
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
select your circle okay control click
like this okay
now keep moving your circle unless
as long as you don't see the orange
colors orange colored guide which snaps
at the very center over here like this
look at that
it is actually getting snapped over here
so the very center over here look at
that okay
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
select both of them together like this
and ctrl g
okay now look it got fixed okay
so we're done making this profile image
over here now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna click it over here like
this and drag it over here but before
that you need to make this card okay so
how to make this card so i'm gonna
double click over here and see its
properties look width is
399 let's consider it 400 okay so 400 by
400 which is a perfect square so i'm
going to come over here
r on my keyboard click over here like
this and what i'm going to write is 400
by 400 okay i'm going to click this over
here and write 400 over here 400 enter
and i'm going to remove the fill from
here completely now let's actually see
the main
image
control click like this and look at this
we have a stroke property of four and
this color okay ctrl c
i'm going to copy this stroke color like
that i'm gonna sit and then i'm gonna
select our
rectangle okay like this if you don't
see the rectangle what you're gonna do
is you're gonna select like this now
look i can see my invisible rectangle
click this uh stroke over here and paste
the color ctrl v enter and then i'm
going to write three over here like this
there we go
now regarding the
now regarding the shadow what you're
gonna do is you're gonna uh click over
here you can just copy and paste the
shadow what you can do is you can select
this over here like this and then click
this effects over here okay and drop
shadow right 10 over here and 10 on the
y-axis as well like this enter
okay now i'm gonna remove the guides
from here by clicking this now you see
this we have a little odd behavior over
here you see this we have white colored
space over here that is unexpected so in
order to remove that
what you're going to do is you're going
to click it over here like this wait a
minute you're going to click this
rectangle over here i mean square over
here and then you're going to fill it
with the color okay color of y complete
pure white okay fff
enter now look the problem is solved
then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna
either write the text over here or copy
the text from here okay control click
alt drag like this okay
and then i'm gonna put my image over
here like this
if you see something like this right
click and
bring it to front like this okay
now ctrl now select both of them
together like this and shift plus a and
then select this option over here keep
it at the middle like this and select
both of them together shift plus a
and then also not shift plus a sorry
click both of them together alt v and
alt h which is center both horizontal
and vertically okay then i'm gonna make
it a group ctrl g like that there we go
we made ourselves a card component over
here along with the profile
picture image now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna replicate the same thing
so pause the video and complete the
process over here and um and i'll be
back after a while all right then we're
done making our teachers page now just
copy this footer from here that you made
earlier okay click over here and then
paste it over here like this there we go
now look at now look at these two pages
over here the contact us page and the
sign up page over here both of them
looks more or less the similar i'm going
to show you how you can make this one
the contact us page and you're going to
make this one the sign up form page on
your own sounds good now let's get
started now i'm gonna now i'm gonna zoom
out and i'm gonna select this over here
by clicking and then shift click shift
click okay i'm gonna uh keep it on the
right side over here like this now i'm
gonna zoom in over here and select a new
create a new frame okay f
and then desktop like this there we go
and i'm going to resize it a little bit
like this wait a minute
there we go now i'm going to copy this
now i'm going to copy this from here
wait a minute i'm going to select both
of them together and
ctrl like this there we go and look we
are in the contact us page which means
that we need to change this
underline okay so i'm going to come to
this original design over here and i'm
going to select this and i'm going to
drag it over here
till this contact us page okay
there we go and then i'm gonna drag it
to cover the
to cover all the area like this and same
thing for the teachers section as well
you see this one over here
so when we are on the sign up page this
underline should be on the signup page
as well okay sounds good now i'm gonna
come back over here now i'm gonna just
copy this text from here
alt
drag it over here like this and in order
to keep it at the very center select
both of them ctrl g and then alt h now
look it's going to be at the very center
of our frame over here now how did i
make this icons along with the address
phone number etc now i'm gonna come back
to my assets page over here and you see
these images over here this icons i'm
gonna copy this from here okay alt and
then drag over here okay
then select both of the all of them
together right click move to page
desktop okay so i'm gonna come back to
desktop zoom out and find uh there is my
icons over here okay then i'm gonna
bring it over here like this and i'm
going to select the k
on my keyboard okay and then i'm going
to resize it like this
okay i'm going to make it a small like
this and i'm going to drag it over here
okay i actually need to make it a little
bit more smaller
wait a minute there we go it looks quite
good and let's actually make it
there we go it looks quite good okay now
regarding the address okay let's inspect
what is the address
font size okay control click look at
that we have 30 pixels font size regular
pop-ins okay so now let's actually uh
duplicate the same thing t
enter
abc abc at the red
gmail.com okay
now in order to center the icon and the
text both horizon both vertically select
both of them together and hit alt h
now look both of them are centered now
ctrl g to lock the position okay now i'm
gonna keep it over here like this and
regarding this one uh select again t
enter okay one two three
four five six okay now look what i do
okay select both of them together
and
alt h there we go by the way i actually
changed my mind instead of making a
group
make it a frame okay so click over here
like this
ctrl shift g to remove the group okay
and hit shift plus a shift plus a like
this and click this over here and put it
at the very center over here like this
now come back over here and let's
inspect this one
what is the gap between our text and the
image over here okay let's inspect by
clicking on here and then alt
put your mouse over here 31 pixels okay
so come back over here click this right
31 over here 31 enter there we go same
thing goes for same thing goes for here
as well
select both of them shift plus a
and click this over here it's going to
be 31 over here 31 enter there we go
keep it over here for now and let's look
at this one it should be um
abc uh comma a d e f okay so t click
like this a b c
comma d e f okay select both of them
together like this shift plus a
keep it at the center like this there we
go
and now select all of them together like
this okay shift plus a
and then keep it at the center over here
like this in order to move it at the
very center hit alt plus h like that
change the gap a little bit to let's say
uh 180 pixels like this
and click over here and again do alt
plus h which is
center horizontally or you can also use
this options over here as well
all right then so far so good now let's
make this input
fields okay
so let's inspect this one over here
control click so 416 pixels by 82 pixels
okay so i'm going to come back over here
like this
hit f on your keyboard
sorry r on your keyboard to make it
rectangle okay like this so it was 416
416 enter
the height was i actually forgot sorry
it was 82 okay so i'm going to click it
over here like this and 8 over here
enter
then i'm gonna remove this fill
by selecting this minus over here okay
minus and then stroke plus
put it to three okay enter
then
increase the corner radius to 12 pixels
okay there we go it looks quite
identical to this one now regarding this
text how do we input the text okay so
i'm going to come over here and
inspect okay control enter
so we have 20 pixels of font size
so i'm gonna come over here and write t
click and write your
name and then dot dot dot like this okay
it should be 20. so it is 20 over here
and now let's center it over here so
select both of them together and alt h
or not alt h sorry
uh alt v like this okay
now i'm going to keep it i'm going to
keep the text uh sorry not this one keep
the text over here like this there we go
it looks quite good
and i'm gonna come back over here and do
you see this it looks this is the
original design do you see this color
over here in order to replicate the same
i'm gonna come to my original design
over here okay i'm gonna control click
over here and do you see this
transparency over here it is set to
hundred percent i wanna set it to fifty
percent okay control fifty enter there
we go we replicated the same thing now
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
click i mean select both of them then
ctrl g i have made a group over here
okay alt
drag like this okay and write your email
over here
email over here like like this okay
there we go
now how do we make this this text over
here the same process okay i'm gonna
control click over here and see it's
inspect the elements okay four one four
y two ten
this is the dimension over here so let's
do it so i'm gonna click over here and
copy it like this over here like this
and i'm just gonna simply drag it over
here like this
there we go and i'm gonna click over
here and ctrl shift g to release the
grouping like that i'm gonna write over
here your message here
message
here okay now i'm gonna select this
option over here you see this option
auto width
there we go and i'm gonna keep it over
here like this
then ctrl g to lock our positions all
right looks good
now let's see the spacing okay i'm gonna
click this first element not this one
and then
hit alt on your keyboard move your mouse
so from here to here it is 50 from here
to here it is how much 46 okay let's
duplicate the same
okay it should be shift plus a
and 46 over here okay and
from here to there it should be uh wait
a minute shift plus a okay and then
center it over here like this
it should be 50 okay write 50 over here
like this 50 enter so we have nailed our
gaps okay now keep it at the very center
okay click this alt h
like that and button and regarding the
button you make the button yourself so
i'm leaving this sign up form to you
this is the same process as this one
okay um
this contact us form and this one over
here
this first page over here i really hope
that you can do it on your own
congratulations guys we have
successfully completed the web design
for the desktop version now we're gonna
create the design for the mobile version
the mobile design is over here on this
page over here by the way if you can
recall i have created these two pages
over here the laptop and the tablet
version over here along with that i have
also included the style guides over here
i mean the typography guides over here
so that you can practice on your own
at your house this is your homework
so i'm gonna come back to mobile version
over here and then i'm gonna show you
how i made this design over here okay so
let's get started all right so first
things first i'm gonna move all of these
elements on the very right side so that
i can
create new frames okay so i'm going to
select all of them together like this
okay like that and then i'm going to
move it by clicking over here and then
drag dragging over here like this all
right
there we go now i'm going to zoom in
here over here like this now i'm gonna
click the f on my keyboard like this and
then i'm gonna select this phone option
over here and then i'm and then i'm
gonna click this over here iphone 11 pro
max like this there we go we have our
frame over here and then i'm gonna align
it like this according to this frame and
then i'm gonna select this one the
original one okay like this and then i'm
gonna look at the
border radius over here i mean corner
radius it is set to 40 pixels okay so
i'm going to click this over here and
i'm going to set it over here how much
40 like this okay enter now let's make
this nav bar over here you see this one
okay so i'm gonna control click on this
logo over here and see its properties it
is set to semi bold pop-pins font family
and font size is 48 pixels over here
okay so i'm going to come back over here
okay click on this
hit t on my keyboard and click okay so
i'm going to write edu
sorry
edu dot io like this and it's also
and then i'm going to change the
settings to for gate over here like this
semi-bold and then pop-ins all right
looks good i'm going to keep it over
here like this there we go now how do
you
create this hamburger menu icon over
here okay so you have two options you
can manually create that or what you can
do is you can
download it from somewhere
i mean download the icon from some
website
like freepik and many others all right
today i'm gonna show you manually how to
create this hamburger menu icon so let's
get started okay so i'm gonna first of
all i'm gonna inspect this element okay
control click like this and then i'm
gonna see its property so how much is it
set width is 30 pixels and the height is
four pixels all right so i'm gonna come
over over here like this and i'm gonna
draw a what rectangle okay
r on my keyboard and then drag it like
this all right i'm gonna write over here
30 and what was the height it was 4 4
enter there we go now i'm going to say
to
which color tell me not black it is this
color i'm going to come to this desktop
option over here and i'm going to come
to my color palette over here you see
this
this color over here okay so i'm gonna
click it over here and copy it like this
all right so i'm gonna go back to the
mobile version and i'm gonna come over
here and i'm gonna paste it over here
like this on this section okay ctrl v
enter boom now i'm going to create it
three times okay i mean replicate it
three times okay
one
so how i did this okay let me show you
ctrl z first of all you're gonna hit alt
on your keyboard okay and then drag your
mouse like this okay there we go and
then do the same thing again like this
alt on your keyboard and drag there we
go now let's come to the original one
over here and what you're gonna do is
you're gonna control
on your keyboard and click like this
okay now hit alt on your keyboard and
then move your mouse to this portion
over here i mean the second line okay so
that you can see the gap between the
first and the second line it is how much
five pixels okay
so i'm gonna come over here
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
multi-select all of them like this okay
and shift plus a
now center it like this
and then i'm going to click it over here
and you see this gap properly i'm going
to set it to five enter there we go
all set now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna center both the logo and
the icon
horizontally okay select both of them
together like this and shift plus a
now look
the icon jumped at the very top let's
fix that by clicking this over here and
keep it at the very center horizontally
like this there we go
now let's come to the original document
over here and click this okay now let's
see its
layout grid okay so i'm going to click
this icon over here like this and then
i'm going to inspect this one okay it
has how many columns one column margin
is 20 pixels
now let's recreate the same okay so i'm
going to click over here like this and
click this okay
layout grid
there we go and i'm going to change it
to what columns and then one over here
and how much is the margin 20 margin
okay there we go
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
i mean we're gonna align it over here
okay i mean the logo and the hamburger
icon okay so we need to increase the gap
so that we can stretch it i mean stretch
the icon to the very right on my on our
layout grid okay like this look at that
okay
there we go
looks good now i'm gonna come back to
the um wait a minute
um yeah it looks good now i'm gonna come
back over here click this okay and now
look what i do i'm gonna select alt on
my keyboard after clicking this nav bar
over here and then alt on my keyboard
and i'm gonna put my mouse on this
screen over here so that i can see the
gap between the screen and my content
okay it is 19 pixel over here and 10
pixel at the top
if i come over here it's going to be the
same i guess no it's strange okay so i'm
going to keep 19 over there okay so how
do i do that what is that uh let's see
okay if it is okay or not okay so i'm
going to click this one alt on my
keyboard and then put my mouse over here
it's 20 over here and over here it is
how much 21 so there is
one pixel difference okay not big
difference okay so let's actually
increase one pixel over here click this
one and then come over here and just
increase one how do you do this pick the
up arrow sign on your keyboard okay like
this
and then the problem is fixed now let's
inspect okay so click this over here alt
on your keyboard put your mouse over
here so it is 20 over here and on this
side alt and then look at this 20 over
here as well but at the top it is how
much nine so
move it a little bit just one one
pixel okay so click this and then down
arrow on your keyboard down like this
now let's inspect alt on your keyboard
keep it over here look at this 10 20 20
it is symmetrical all right looks good
now regarding the image how do we work
with this
same thing come to your assets over here
and look at this one okay
click on here alt on your keyboard drag
over here like this okay right click
move to page what mobile all right so
zoom out a little bit so that we can see
where
our
asset got transferred okay so it is
transferred over here bring it over here
like this and the drill is the same okay
you're gonna double click over here or
what you can do is you can just click on
here or not here sorry over here and
you're gonna select i mean you're gonna
see all of this vector gets selected
okay just select the very last one okay
this one and delete
on your keyboard
like this
it got deleted and look at this white
space if i click this name over here you
see this unnecessary white space in
order to remove them click this frame
over here and select group there we go
all our unnecessary white space white
spaces went away so i'm going to keep it
over here and look it's very big okay so
we need to resize it we scale it either
you can hit k either you can hit k on
your keyboard or just hit shift
on your keyboard and just drag it over
here like this all right
like this let's do it manually instead
of copying the properties from here okay
let's manually uh shift
hold shift on your keyboard and drag it
like this okay it's gonna
resize proportionately like this okay
now you're gonna follow the orange
guides
now you're gonna follow the orange
guides over here you see these orange
guides let me zoom in you can see the
orange colored guides okay you see these
guides you see that it's snapping okay
so i'm gonna stretch it till my layout
grid over here okay there we go boom now
let's inspect the gap between our nav
item i mean nav bar and our image okay
on the original document click this alt
on your keyboard and put it over here
47. so click this alt on your keyboard
put it over here so 36.71
so what was this 47 okay so i'm gonna um
sorry i'm gonna um
put it over here let's say
this much gap click over here and alt to
put it over here it's 58 okay it should
be 47 so
shift plus up
let's see how much is that we have moved
10 pixel up
so alt on your keyboard this 48 so it
was 47 so click it click again and put i
mean press up arrow sign one thing like
this now look it's
equal
measurement all right
and regarding this flakes over here you
see these little flakes
okay
you're gonna put them on your own okay
so i'm gonna leave it as it is because i
showed you how to recreate these doodles
over here this flakes over here okay
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
come to this assets over here okay and
then you're gonna use this assets over
here okay
all right let's come back to the mobile
over here now let's duplicate this text
over here and create the button all
right now click this alt on your
keyboard and drag over here like this
okay
by the way i also give you this chart
over here the typography guide like what
should be the size font size of the logo
then the large text small text size
button etc so that you can make all the
elements with accurate calculations okay
so zoom out and come over here
all right then so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna copy this over here as well
okay like this click over here alt
drag like this all right there we go now
let's see how to create this button over
here okay the same thing okay what
you're gonna do is you're gonna hit t on
your keyboard okay then
click like this now you're gonna write
log
in like this okay now come over here and
inspect the original document click
hit control and then click
now look we have
font size of 24
roboto
both all right so come over here right
24
uh roboto
robo 2
and then it should be how much both
there we go
and we're gonna change the color to
white because it is because the original
button is white in color all right
like this fff three times or right six
times okay it looks invisible now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna hit
shift plus a on your keyboard and make
auto layout like the shift plus a
okay
in case if you can't find your invisible
button over here do this okay if you
select like this then you can select
your button all right
now come at the bottom over here and hit
fill and fill it with the color black
zero zero zero enter there we go now we
can see our button
okay so come over here click i mean
control click look at the height it is
55 ah 0.41 let's consider it 55 and the
width is 374 which is
i mean which stretches from the very
left to the very right to our layout
grid so
um what is the border yes 9.49 okay so
click over here write the border here i
mean corner radius 9.49
all right there we go now the height is
how much 55 look at this the height and
the weight is locked in order to unlock
it just
come over here and drag it a little bit
over here like this resize it a little
bit over here the height gets unlocked
and do the same over here little bit
over here
the width gets unlocked as well all
right now in order to
if you notice carefully then you can see
that the text is not at the very center
of a button how to do it
just click over here
center like this both horizontal and
vertically okay now the height of the
button should be 55 enter and the width
instead of doing it
manually instead of doing it over here
directly just put it over here like this
and then drag like this okay
extend till the end over here like this
okay there we go now copy the button
over here like this
all right now control click
double click over here and then sign
up
there you go and then what you're gonna
do is you're gonna click both of them
then hit shift plus a
and now center the button both
horizontally vertically together like
this all right now let's inspect the gap
between our first and the second button
okay click
sorry control click
control click on the original button and
then alt
put your mouse over here how much it is
17 pixels so gap okay so come over here
and click this and it should be 17 17.
there we go
all right now looks good now i'm gonna
remove the layout grid from here like
this okay along with that remove the
layout grid of the original document as
well look at that it looks symmetrical
identical
except the flakes over here okay except
this flakes over here because i have
kept this for you so that you can do it
on your own all right now look at the
second frame over here this is the same
as the first one okay so what you have
to do is you're gonna click f on your
keyboard then phone come to phone option
and then click iphone 11 pro max like
this and you're gonna get this frame
over here like this resize it uh you
don't have to resize it because it's
perfect measurement and then what you're
going to do is you're going to come to
this one over here okay click over here
alt drag like this and then paste it
over here like this there we go and
regarding this one inspect the
corner yes it is 40 pixels so 40 pixel
over here as well four zero enter and
regarding layout grid click over here
okay set it to uh columns 20 of gap i
mean 20 pixel gap column count should be
one okay enter there we go and now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna
center it over here like this
at the very center vertically or what
you can do is you can just keep it over
here like this and just click it and alt
h which means center horizontally like
this or what you have the or you also
have this option over here you see this
we have the align horizontal centers
okay i'm going to keep it over here like
this click it over here click this look
at that it got centered horizontally
all right so i'm gonna keep it over here
like this according to according to our
design over here all right now i'm gonna
leave this entire design on your hands
because i truly believe that you can do
it on your own because this one is
similar to this one over here the first
frame over here okay so i'm not doing
this you're gonna do it okay including
this little doodles over here okay so
you're gonna do this on your own as well
now we're gonna move on to the next
section over here you see this we're
going to make cards over here on our
offered courses section okay so how do
we do this okay so first of all create a
frame over here f on your keyboard okay
and then select this iphone 11 pro max
okay align it over here like this i mean
with the original document at the top
like this look at that we have our
orange colored guides over here okay now
click on this select the corner radius
corner radius to 40 over here enter
there we go and now we're going to
stretch it
till over here unless as long as it
doesn't snap over here at the bottom you
can see the orange colored guides if i
zoom in a little bit over here you can
see the orange colored guides okay
there we go
i mean it's gonna snap okay you can feel
it that it
aligned together
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
click our frame over here by selecting
this name over here and then
layout grid all right click on this and
select columns just one column enter all
right now click on the original document
over here and
select this not this sorry this one okay
let's let's inspect how much
margin do we have we have 20 pixels of
margin okay so this one on our practice
case it should be 20 pixels of margin as
well so click
so so click over here and select 20 okay
enter there we go now regarding this nav
bar you know the drill right just
copy it from here like this alt and then
drag over here like this there we go and
in order to center this nav bar
horizontally what you're gonna do you
remember alt h or select anyone or
select this option over here okay all
right looks good keep it over here at
the top okay now in order to complete
these designs very quickly what you're
gonna do is you're gonna come to this
desktop option over here okay and this
is our offered courses this is the
original one and this is the practice
case over here okay so i'm going to
click over here and and then select alt
on my keyboard and drag over here like
this all right look at that
i have successfully copied it and now
right click move to page what mobile all
right come to mobile zoom out to find
the frame that is it we have our there
is it we have our frame over here
drag it over here like this okay and
this corner and now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna select this
text over here along with the underline
okay
copy it through alt drag like this all
right
there we go and now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna
shift and then resize like this
or what you can do you can just
you're gonna hit k on your keyboard and
drag like this all right now look at
this it is getting small proportionality
okay now i'm gonna keep it over here you
can take the help of the orange colored
guides like this okay or what you can do
is you can just keep it over here as it
is and click it alt h or select this
option okay align content horizontally
there we go and let's inspect the gap
between this one and the nav
nav bar click this alt and put your
mouse over here 38 pixels okay click
over here alternate keyboard put it over
here it is 59 okay so what you have to
do is you have to just keep it over here
and
let's inspect right now alt on my
keyboard select 40 okay
so i'm gonna click here and then
press the up arrow two times one two now
it's 38
accurately all right looks good if you
can if you can recall we made these
cards on the desktop version okay
controls that that set now in order to
make the
design for the mobile version very
quickly we're gonna take the help of or
allow so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna select all our cards together like
this okay and then shift plus a like
this do you see this option over here
this is called the aura layout do you
see this little button over here oh by
the way you're gonna click this over
here and then center both horizontal and
vertically okay like this and now do you
see this little button over here this is
activated which is which is align
content horizontally now we're gonna
select align content vertically like
this
you see this button over here click this
now look
it made us content for our mobile
version okay so i'm gonna drag from here
to here like this okay and then i'm
gonna what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
keep it i mean align with our layout
grid over here like this all right now
i'm going to select k on my keyboard
or
hold shift and then resize your
cards like this
as long as it doesn't snap to our
layout grid on the right okay like this
look at that
there we go it looks quite good i guess
click over here and put it at the top
like this
there we go
okay now it looks quite big compared to
our design over here so in order to
adjust the settings what we're gonna do
is we're gonna click over here double
click okay and then double click again
double click again as long as we don't
see this blue colored lines around our
image okay look at the size of the image
okay you see this just copy the width
ctrl c and now come over here double
click double click double click as long
as you don't see the
blue colored lines around our image okay
so i have selected this one select this
option okay constraints properly
then paste the width over here control v
enter there we go now let's change the
text what is the font size of this text
okay control click
now look at this it is 50.7 just
consider it 50 pixels okay control click
set it to 50 5 0 enter there we go
and yeah select this option over here as
well auto width
so what it will do uh let me show you
okay control z what it will do you see
this extra gap over here it's gonna
remove that extra extra gap so that we
can do our measurements accordingly i
mean
correctly okay so click this over here
now now you can see that the extra gap
got removed okay like that
there we go and you're getting the
button let's inspect the button what is
the font size of the bottom okay control
click like this 24 pixels okay control
click so it to 24 over here enter and
then look at this we have so many gaps
over here okay in order to remove those
gaps just click this over here auto
wait like this there we go
all right so far so good now look at
this we have our content on the very
left side so we need to
center it both horizontal and vertically
and now let's look at our original card
over here okay so double click over here
and look at this height over here okay
so i'm going to copy the height okay
ctrl c and then come to our practice
case over here okay double click over
here and then paste it over here like
this okay ctrl v enter
all right now so far so good now we need
to center our content both horizontally
and vertically inside our card over here
okay so how do we do this first of all
we're gonna unframe our frame okay like
this i'm gonna click over here and then
click this over here okay from frame
we're gonna select it to group like this
okay and then ctrl shift g to remove
that group like this now look it doesn't
have any
auto layout over here it is just a
single plane card i look at this over
here it is also behaving like a group so
ctrl shift g remove that group as well
all right now the next thing that you're
gonna do is you're gonna click this
content over here and this button over
here as well okay both of them and then
shift plus a to put it inside a frame
okay and then select it to zero like
this and then enter all right
zero over here as well there we go
it is removing the extra white space
from our content okay and now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna select
both the card and our content like this
okay and then shift plus a okay shift a
and then
center it both horizontal and vertical
okay you're gonna select this button
over here like this and then select this
button over here or what you can do is
you can just select alt
h and alt v on your keyboard like this
look
alt v h like this there we go
now look at this we have so many gaps
over here but we have a minimum gap over
here okay so how do we remove those gaps
okay so let's inspect this button over
here okay control click like this look
at this properties okay look at the
height it is 55 pixels okay so i'm going
to come back over here and control click
like this
and set the height to how much it is set
to 62. so and it is also locked so what
you're gonna do is you're gonna select v
on your keyboard and drag it a little
bit up okay and now set it to
55 pixels okay 55 enter there we go
now look this button is not at the very
same i mean this text is not at the very
center what you're gonna do is you're
gonna click this over here okay and then
center it over here like this there we
go boom but still we have so many gaps
in our content okay so let's inspect
okay so click over here and look at this
we have 17.66 pixels of cap okay so
let's let's say to zero enter
there we go
now select both of them together again
and alt v alt h to center both of them
both horizontally and vertically there
we go our button looks exactly the
carbon copy of the original one over
here
now i'm gonna leave the rest of these
cards you see this card over here and
this card over here as well i am leaving
this to you fix them along with that
this design over here you see this
design this is similar to our design i
mean frame number one this one and frame
number two over here as well so do it on
your own and yeah you're gonna do this
footer over here as well on your own now
we're gonna make the teachers page okay
this one all right so zoom out a little
bit and delete this one from here delete
all right and then we're gonna move it
to the right side
select properly like this all right so
right side over here like this there we
go
and now
come to the desktop version over here
and you see this
page over here
the original document this one so i'm
going to copy it from here okay the
original design okay click on the name
over here desktop four alt on your
keyboard and drag it over here like this
all right now right click move to page
which one mobile like this okay now come
to the mobile version zoom out find it
where is it here is it okay so i'm going
to keep it over here at the top and i'm
going to move it uh both of them i mean
all this design little design is over
here on the very right over here okay
now zoom in over here
click f on your keyboard select the
iphone 11 pro max like this okay drag it
over here like this and set the
border radius i mean cornered yes to 40
over here like this enter now select
this layout grid set it to columns over
here and then count would be one enter
set the margin to 20 pixels over here
enter all right now just
just replicate the
nav bar by alt
on your keyboard drag over here like
this all right then release it like this
and then alt h center hor to center
horizontally like this okay there we go
so far so good now look at this desktop
design over here okay so alt
drag like this okay keep it over here
then and then hit k on your keyboard
okay k
and then drag it like this as long as it
doesn't get shrunk
like this okay like this one the
original design
let's make it let's make it a little bit
smaller like this
and then click on here select this or
alt h on your keyboard there we go
keep it a little bit up
like this all right looks good
and now select your frame over here like
this and then hit v on your keyboard
okay v and then drag it to the very end
over here like this
there we go
so far so good now we're gonna replicate
the cards over here okay so how many
cards do we have one two three sorry one
two three um four
five okay five cards
not six cards as the original design
online on the desktop version okay so so
do you recall that how we made these
cards over here okay so
what will we use over here the same as
this one over here you see this design
over here we made this
same as this one we're gonna use the
auto layout how do we do this like this
look at look follow me okay i'm gonna
select all my cards over here like this
shift plus a or right click and add auto
layout like this look at this little
button over here okay it is horizontal
say to vertical like this look
it became designed for our mobile
version you see this okay i'm gonna keep
it over here like this
there we go
all right and then i'm gonna resize it
by hitting k on my keyboard and resizing
like this
as long as uh you see this one as long
as this one this line doesn't align with
our
layout grid okay like this there we go
boom
and i'm going to keep it over here like
this
and we're getting this cards over here
same thing follow the same thing okay
select all of them together and then
shift plus a and then click this over
here like this all right now keep it
over here like this and then resize it
like this okay k on your keyboard and
then resize like this actually it is
very big so i'm going to keep it over
here like this
now what you're gonna do is do it
remember how i resize this first frame
over here okay on our offered courses
section
this one do you remember how i resize
this
card according to the original design
you're gonna do the same thing over here
okay you're gonna first of all resize
this card and then this two and then
you're gonna resize these two cards over
here and by the way you don't need the
last one okay so like we can easily i
mean we can delete this one okay like
this delete
we have two cards over here
oh by the way we can also place it over
here like this there we go
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
resize these cards according to the
original file over here i mean the
original designer i showed you how to do
it right over here
i showed you how to resize it according
to the original design so do it on your
own
do this section on your own because i
truly believe that you can do it
and regarding this footer over here you
don't have to recreate it again because
it is a component
i mean this is the original component
over here wait a minute this is the
original component over here and this
one wait a second this one is an
instance of the original document okay
so this is just an instance okay just
copy it from here alt and then drag over
here like this there we go
and if you in case if you want to change
something over here just change the
original document okay just change over
here and everything i mean all the
children
will get changed according to the parent
component okay
all right now let's look how to make
this contact us form okay this one over
here
so we're gonna create i mean we're gonna
move this to the very right side like
this select all of them together and
then drag to the right side like this
there we go and then come over here and
hit f on your keyboard f you're gonna
click f on your keyboard and then select
this iphone 11 pro max like this keep it
over here and what was the
corner radius you remember 40 pixels so
hit
40 over here okay 40 enter then auto
layout i mean layout grid over here
set it to columns over here like this
columns and then set one enter and over
here right 20 pixels of margin
there we go
just copy the nav bar from here because
we made it once
right and then what you're gonna write
is i mean what you're gonna click is
this one align horizontal centers there
we go boom
keep it up at the top like this there we
go or you can just use your mouse and
move it like this there we go keep it
over here
and
just copy this text from here
click and then drag like this all right
and in order to take it i mean in order
to keep it at the center alt h on your
keyboard alt h
move it a little bit up
uh like this and if you want accurate
measurements just select this and alt on
your keyboard and drag keep keep your
mouse over here it is 15 pixels okay so
i'm gonna keep i'm gonna click over here
keep my mouse over here like this is 30
pixels okay so let's move it a little
bit up so how to do it click over here
and then hold shift on your keyboard and
press up like this
one two
okay now let's inspect click over here
alt on your keyboard look it is 10
pixels of gap so click over here one two
three four five i pressed five times the
arrow down button on my on my keyboard
like that look at that it is now
accurate measurements
all right now copy
this line from here as well i'll drag
over here like this okay
then alt h
to center horizontally now keep it over
here at the bottom of the get in touch
text all right now how to recreate them
do you remember where are our assets it
is over here on this assets page all
right not this one um
this one over here wait a second there's
one okay so i'm gonna select all of them
together like this and then alt drag
like this then
select all of them again right click
move to page where come on tell me it's
mobile
so come to mobile over here zoom out to
see where is it here is it okay i'm
gonna select all of them together like
this and then
select k on my keyboard and drag or
select
shift on my keyboard okay and then drag
like this and then it's gonna get
resized like that okay i'm gonna bring
it over here like this look at that
okay so it's uh quite fake compared to
this one you can you can also inspect
the icon size like this control click
like this and you can see that it is
width 50 pixels
and the height is
38.09 pixels okay so you can do that as
well but i'm gonna just
use my scale tool okay so i'm gonna
select all of them together and then hit
k on my keyboard and then scale it down
like this there we go
all right now now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna
select this phone over here like this
okay i mean we're gonna make it
horizontal like this okay now let's copy
the text from here okay alt
drag like this
double click
alt drag like this okay or just click
over here i mean control click over here
and then alt
no sorry alt drag over here like this
or what you can do is just control click
over here like this and then alt
drag like this all right now what you're
gonna do is look at this very carefully
i'm gonna select both of them together
and take the help of whom home
auto layout okay the boss is over here
click it over here like this the plus
sign all right now keep it at the very
center over here both the text and the
icon like this there we go
now let's keep a gap of 30 pixel okay
between our icon and the text okay the
same thing from for here shift a
click over here and center it over here
like this all right
now
how much was the gap 30 pixels okay
select this curry enter boom
the same over here shift a
how much 30 enter see like this keep it
at the very center over here okay now so
far so good it looks like this one okay
now if you now if you notice carefully
then you can see that this text are not
aligned to a single line okay so let me
bring my ruler over here like this by
clicking over here and then
rulers over here like this so i got my
so i got my ruler over here then i'm
gonna click over here and then keep my
ruler over here like this look at that
so i'm gonna keep it over here okay to
this line now if i zoom in then you can
see that
the text is over here okay according to
our ruler and but this text doesn't
align with our ruler over here at the
same time this text doesn't align with
our ruler over here that's because the
width of this icon width of this icon
and the width of this icon is not the
same so in this cases what you're gonna
do is you're gonna just remove that aura
layout how to remove the order layout
okay click over here and select this
group
and then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna click this and then ctrl shift g
on your keyboard to remove that group
now look both of them behaves like an
individual elements all right same thing
over here remove the frame to group and
then ctrl shift key to remove that group
come over here
select this frame to group okay ctrl
shift key remove that group there we go
now what you're going to do is you're
going to select all the text over here
like this okay and then
use oral layout shift plus a like this
now look our text are at the very center
over here according to our what
according to this ruler over here you
see this ruler and you see this
content over here now if you want to you
can also use this one and then keep it
over here okay on the left side of the
horizontal line like this
all right
now regarding this uh icons over here
you can do the same you can just use
auto layout as well
by clicking all of them together i mean
selecting all of them together and then
shift plus a
and then we you need to keep it at the
center both horizontally and vertically
so click over here and then click this
all right then so far so good okay now
we're gonna select all of them together
like this okay and then ctrl g on your
keyboard to lock the position all right
there we go look at that it looks very
nice now click this original document
over here like this all right and then
alternate keyboard put your mouse over
here like this how much is the gap
between our address and this text 46
let's duplicate the same as well click
over here and then keep it over here
like this
and then alternate keyboard keep it over
here how much how much is this 53 so you
have to go how much nine more steps okay
so hit nine times
the up arrow sign okay one two three
four five six seven eight nine now let's
inspect okay click on here
alt and then put your mouse over here
44 uh wait a minute it was how much
uh sorry
46 oh sorry i moved two pixel up so i'm
gonna go two pixels down so
click two times
the down arrow okay one two
now it's gonna be
exact measurement okay so click on here
out and then put it over here like this
46
there we go
now let's create this form over here
okay so let's inspect the first one okay
click
ctrl click over here like this how much
is the height
63.99 let's consider 64 okay so come
over here and if you want to remove the
ruler what you're gonna do is you're
gonna click over here and then select
this rulers and the ruler will go away
like that now hit r on your keyboard and
drag it like this how much was the
height 65 right
uh 64 all right so i'm going to click
over here and write 64 enter
and i'm going to keep it over here like
this and i'm going to drag it until i
don't cover the entire width of my
layout grid like that now what is the
border radius corner yes it's 9.36
so of the original design so i'm going
to click over here and write
9.9.36 over here enter there we go
and then
add some stroke like this how much three
enter
not three sorry let's consider it two
enter there we go
now you can see that this form at the
top
and over here are the similar i mean
similar identical so what you're gonna
do is you're gonna alt on your keyboard
and drag over here like this all right
and regarding this one
the same over here as well drag it over
here like this
and then drag like this there we go boom
and listen let's remove our all layout i
mean the layout grid from here by
selecting this or you can also remove it
permanently
but don't do that okay just select this
one and it's gonna get removed i mean
the auto layout so come at the bottom
over here you see this forms over here
select this and remove the fill
and it's gonna get white just like our
original document over here okay the
same for this one
and do the same for this one as well
now i'm leaving the rest of the work to
you
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
place this text you see this text over
here this text this text this text and
the button on our practice case over
here okay i believe that you can do it
all right all right now do you remember
our last frame over here this is the
same as this one wait a minute this one
this frame the contact us frame and this
one okay the first frame over here okay
the process is the same you have to do
it on your own i'm leaving this i'm
leaving this to you
all right guys personally i think that
this video became extremely long so what
kind of content do you want do you want
very big in-depth tutorial videos or
short videos let me know in the comments
down below
so ladies and gentlemen we're done with
our tutorial if you like the video give
a like share with a friend and feel free
to subscribe
till then i'll see you in the next video
bye bye